REVIEW CAN WILL COME TO A GIVE.
IN RESPONSE TO THE COLBERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING THAT IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS HOLDING THIS
ESSENTIAL HEARING AND IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WHILE CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES. OUR
POUNDS FOR THE PART OF FINANCE
IN THE LA OFFER WILL BE RICH.
TO THE USE OF THE VIDEO COM
SERVE. FOR THE PALACE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS.
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MEETING AND I'M
MEETING THEMSELVES WHEN THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. THIS WILL
GREATLY AIDED ELIMINATED
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU HAVE A COMMENT
OR QUESTION YOU USE THE RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. ONCE RECOGNIZE TO
SPEAK PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
BEFORE YOU SPEAK. HELLO THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCE
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. IT WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY ON TODAY'S AGENDA. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANTS FREE NUMBER ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED. ON OUR
COMMUNITY WEB ON OUR COMMITTEE.
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. WILL
MOVED TO PULL COM. ON WILL I DO.
YOU IN THE- OPEN YOUR LINE AND
THAT TIME YOU MANAGE THE COULD.
PLEASE NOTE. THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AT TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE. YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. WE WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND IN
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS
IN AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS
WHO ARE ADJUSTING TO THE USE OF
NEW ONLINE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGY. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT TO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD
WE HAVE THREE TRAILER BILL FOR
DISCUSSION ON TODAY'S AGENDA IN
ADDITION TO A BRIEF OVERVIEW
FROM THE LA I'LL- ON THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE SENATE
VERSION OF THE BUDGET. THAT WE
HEARD AND PASSED IN THIS
COMMITTEE TWO WEEKS AGO. AND
THE LEGISLATIVE AGREEMENT. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WE WILL HEAR
ALL THREE OF THE TRAILER BILLS
PRIOR TO TAKING ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT AND VOTING. ONCE WE
HAVE HEARD ALL OF THE DEALS WE
WILL HAVE WON THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO COMMENT ON ANY OF THE
THREE TRAILER BILLS WE ARE NOT
TAKING PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
BUDGET. IN CHIEF. SUBSEQUENT TO
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD WE
WILL VOTE ON THE THREE TRAILER
BILLS. BEFORE WE GET INTO THE
AGENDA ITEMS LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATORS MITCHELL HERE
PRESENT NIELSEN. I SENT WELL I
SENT CARILLO PRESIDENT PRESENT
DOLLAR THEY'RE ALSO HERE ARE
ALSO PRESENT FURTADO LEYVAYOUR
PRESENT MAKE IT MCGUIRE REQUIRE
PRESENT MELINDA. MULLIN DOES
MONEY MONEY PER MORE LAW
PRESIDENT MORE LIKE PRESS FOR A.
MORRELL PRESENT PAN HAMPER ROTH
HERE ROUGH FOR SKINNER. STERN
WHY BECAUSE HE HERE BECAUSE HE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU MUCH
ABOUT SO SELLING CALL TODAY THE
SENATE BUDGET INTO REVIEW IS ME
TO TAKE ACTION ON THREE BUDGET
FOR BILL THAT WILL BE TAKEN UP
BY THE FLOOR COMING MONDAY DO
FIFTH. ALONG WITH THE BY BILL
FOR THE TWO TWENTY ONE FISCAL
YEAR THE BUDGET BILL IS S.
SEVEN FOUR AND IT WILL BE
COMING OVER TO FROM THE IS. THE
BUDGET THAT WE BE VOTER ON BY A
GREEN BUT THE SAN TENNIS AND AS
SOME TO THE BUDGET THE BY THIS
COMMITTEE AT OUR LAST HEARING.
ALL WE DON'T PHYSICALLY THE
BUDGET BILLING. WHEN IT'S
COMING FROM ANOTHER HOUSE GIVEN
THE UNIQUE SIR. THAT WE'VE
ENCOUNTERED THIS YEAR AS A
RESULT OF CALLED NINETEEN.
TODAY I'VE ASKED THE LA L. TWO
GIVEN OVERVIEW OF THE KEY
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
SENATE'S VERSION OF THE BUDGET.
AND THE LEGISLATIVE AGREEMENT.
THE LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET
AGREEMENT BILLS OFF OF THE
FRAMEWORK OF THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE. OUR BUDGET IS BALANCED
AND MEETS THE OBJECTIVES OF THE
DRESS IN THE CURRENT SHOW
SHORTFALL THAT WE FACE WHILE
MINIMIZING HARMFUL CUTS. WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO THANK THE LA
OLD OFFICE AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR PARTICIPATING AND
WILL RECOGNIZE THE VICE CHAIR
IF HE HAS ANY OPENING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND-
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THIS GOING
TO BE ONE OF THE MORE DIFFICULT
BUDGETS THAT WE'VE HAD TO DEAL
WITH. THE CORONAVIRUS SITUATION
IS GREATLY CHANGED
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR US AND
COMPROMISED THE BUDGET PROCESS
IF YOU CAN CALL IT A PROCESS.
THE IT IT'S MORE A SCRUM THESE
DAYS UNFORTUNATELY. WE'VE
PROBABLY DONE THE BEST WE CAN
BUT IN TERMS OF THE PUBLIC THIS
IS NOT A BUDGET THAT WE KNOW A
LOT ABOUT. USUALLY WE SPEND
COUNTLESS HOURS OVER MONTHS IN
OUR SUBCOMMITTEE WORK TO REALLY
SCRUTINIZE EACH AGENCIES BUDGET
AND THE VARIOUS SUBJECT AREAS
WE'VE NOT BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT
WE HAD ONE HEARING. AND NOW WE
ARE CONFRONTED WITH THE-
DECISION TO GET A BUDGET OUT
HERE BY THE FIFTEEN. THE BUDGET
THAT'S PREDICATED ON QUESTION
MARKS IN THE FUTURE. THAT'S A
DIFFICULT WAY TO BUILD A BUDGET.
WE'RE GOING TO DO THE BEST WE
CAN AND I SUPPOSE WE HAVE THUS
FAR I WILL HAVE SOME COMPLAINTS
ABOUT SOME ASPECT OF THE BUDGET.
AND WE DO HAVE TO GET A BUDGET.
BUT KEEP IN MIND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE SOLVING FUTURE
PROBLEMS FOR THE MOST PART
WE'RE PUTTING THINGS ASIDE
KICKING IT DOWN THE ROAD JUST A
BIT. INCLUDING PREDICATE IN A
LOT OF HOPE. IN FEDERAL FUNDS
OF WHICH I DON'T HAVE MUCH
CONFIDENCE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
VICE CHAIR SO LET'S BEGIN WITH
THE LA ALL WHO GIVE US A BRIEF
OVERVIEW AGAIN OF THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE SENATE
VERSION OF THE BUDGET. AND THE
LEGISLATIVE AGREEMENT THAT WE
WILL HERE ON THIS FLOOR ON
MONDAY GOOD MORNING MR PECK
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR- YES MY
NAME IS GAVE CREDIT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. AND AS YOU
SAID AS AS THE CHAIR SAID IT
TODAY WILL PRESENT. SUMMARY
DESCRIBING SOME OF THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE EARLIER
TALKED ABOUT SENATE BUDGET
PACKAGE AND THE LEGISLATIVE
AGREEMENT. BUDGET PACKAGE. MY
REMARKS ARE OUTLINED BY THE
BRIEF HANDOUT WHICH I HOPE THAT
YOU HAVE. AND FOR THOSE
FOLLOWING A LINE IT CAN BE
FOUND AT OUR WEBSITE ILIO DOT
C. H. GOV. MY REMARKS WILL BE
BRIEF BECAUSE IN THE TO PASS
ARE FERRIES TO ONE ANOTHER.
THEY TAKE A BROAD LEAF APPROACH.
RATHER S. ON. MAY SPENDING
ASSUMPTION. AND A SIMILAR
APPROACH TO ASSUMPTIONS WITH
REGARD TO THE RECEIPT OF
FEDERAL. SO WHAT THAT MOVED TO
THE FIRST PAGE OF THE HANDOUT
BECAUSE- HERE IT DOES. ON THE
SLIDE A CUP OF THEIR- IN WHICH
THE LET'S JUST BY PACK WITH
PROVIDE SOME OUR- RELICS TO THE
SENATE BUDGET PACKAGE. THE
FIRST ITEM LIST THERE THE
COUNTY RELYING ASSIST. YOU'LL
SEE THAT THE LETTER BODY
PACKAGE WITH PROVIDE FOR HER
BILLION MORE IN ONE. A FOR REAL
PRO THE MISTER BUDGET
CONTEMPLATED. AND ANOTHER AREA
OF I'M IS THE ABOUT A MILLION
MORE LOCAL. HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAM FUNDING. SO THAT WOULD
THREE HUNDRED AND MILLION
RATHER THAN THE TWO AND FIFTY
MILLION THE SENATE BUDGET
PACKAGE. AND THEN. NEED THAT
THERE IS ADDITION FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE. YOU'LL SEE THE LAW
PACKAGE PROVIDE SOME BASIC
FUNDING ARE GOING TO FOR THE-
OF THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
MILLION. THE LATEST BUDGET MAIN
THE TO THE EARNED INCOME TAX.
THAT THIS PACKAGE IN CASE. THIS
THAT IT WOULDN'T THE X. TO TAX
FILING AYE INTO TACK I.
INDIVIDUAL TAX IDEA NOT. IT
INTO THOSE INDIVIDUAL WITH
KNOWLEDGE AGES SIX AND I. THE
LEGISLATIVE BY PACKAGE DOES HOW
MAKE A TECHNIQUE JUST TO THAT
AND SO YOU SEE IT'S THIS SIXTY
FIVE MILLION RATHER THAN FORTY
TO ME. THEN MOVING TO THE PAGE.
THIS IS A SLIDE WERE WE SOME
THE NOTED DIFFERENCE BUT THE
TWO. BEGINNING WITH THE MANAGED
CARE. HAVE IN THE SENATE.
THROUGH AN S. THERE WAS.
PROVISION THAT WOULD. MAKE AN
ADJUSTMENT TO THE MCO TAX TO
GENERATE AROUND DOLLARS OF GEN
FUND SAVINGS THE EVENT THAT
THERE IS NO FEDERAL. THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE JUST
INCLUDE THIS FOR. THEN IN
ADDITION DE LEGISLATIVE PACK
TAKES DIFFERENT TO THE MAILER
PROPOSAL TO ESTABLISH A COVERT
NOW CONTENDED FUND AS YOU
RECALL THE NEIGHBOR INCLUDED A
PROPOSAL TO CREATE THIS COMMENT.
CONTINGENCIES WHICH WOULD BE TO
PAY NINE. I THAT SEVEN AND SEE
MILLION WAS GOING TO BE FROM
THE GENERAL FROM A GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION. WITH THE
REMAINING TWO POINT TWO BILLION.
REALLY COMING FROM AN
ANTICIPATED RECEITA THE MASS
FUNDS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. SO THE LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET PACKAGE TAKES A
DIFFERENT APPROACH HERE IN
MOVING TO TAKE A SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SIXTEEN MILLION AND
DESIGNATED WITHIN SPECIAL FUND
FOR ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY AND
THAT DESIGNATION WOULD BE. KIND
OF YOUR MARK IN A WAY FOR A
CODE RELATED ACTIVITIES RATHER%
THAN CREATING THAT THE CALL
WITH NINETY CONTENT FUND.
ANOTHER DE IS WITH REGARD TO
THE- DEFERRAL OF THE JUNE AND
STATE WORKER PAYROLL- FROM JUNE
TO JULY. SO THE LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET PACKAGE RATHER THAN
INCLUDING THAT OUT RIGHT IT
DOES INCLUDED BUT IT MAKES THE
DEFERRAL CONTENTION ON EIGHT
JANUARY DETERMINATION SO IN
JANUARY. YES THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ESTIMATES THAT THE
STATE'S FISCAL CONDITION IS
BETTER THAN IT IS AT THE TIME
OF BUDGET ENACTMENT AND BY THAT
WE WOULD YOU KNOW THINK OF
REVENUES BEING HIGHER OR
EXPENDITURES BEING LOWER THAN
IT THEN AS SOON GET THE TIME OF
BUDGET ENACTMENT IF THAT'S THE
CASE THEN THE DEFERRAL WOULD
NOT BE MADE. HOWEVER IF THE
STATE'S FISCAL CONDITION IS
DETERMINED TO BE. NOT AS STRONG
AT THAT IN JANUARY THEN THE
DEFERRAL WOULD BE MADE. THEN
LAST LESS TWO ITEMS OF OUR ONE
IS IN THE OF THEM COME. THE
LATEST BUDGET. INCLUDES BETWEEN
ONE POINT FIVE BILL TO POINT
NINE BILLION OF US YOU STATING
BUT ONLY IN THE THAT THERE IS
NO DISH FEDERAL. THAT BECOMES A
IN THE COMING MY- AND THEN
LASTLY. THE SENATE BUDGET. YOU
RECALL INCLUDED ARE. FOR THE CA
THROUGH CAN YOU COLLEGE
PROGRAMS OF NINE BILLION
DOLLARS. AND I AM THE
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PACKAGE
MAINTAINS THIS APPROACH USING
THE DEFERRALS. BUT IT ACTION
DOESN'T IT BY ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
MILLION TO ACCOUNT FOR IT
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT THAT WAS
ME. AND SO WITH THAT ARE THE
MAIN. THE MAIN DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE BUDGET PACKED IN
THE SAN BUDGET THE CONSIDER
PREVIOUS. AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO.
TAKE QUESTIONS OR WITH LIKE.
WHEN IT'S- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR PATRICK I APPRECIATE YOU
AND WANTED. THAT OF MY
COLLEAGUES THE AND WHOM SAY
SENATE VERSUS LEDGES. OF THE TO
CALL WHERE. THE TO PAY TO GO
DEAL WITH THE US AND THE SENATE
THAT'S- LET THE HE CALLED LEAD
TO FIT AGREEMENT IN THE REPORT
THANK YOU. MISTER THIS WILL NOT
ON DEPARTMENT. DIDN'T ANYTHING
YOU'D LIKE TO ADD TO LOW. WHAT
MR PAY. BECOME FROM USER. OF
ALL WE SAY THAT WE THAT IF
PARTY GO SHE ARE. ALL THIS WEEK
ANALYZE WAIT FOR THE WEEKEND SO
WE LOOK FORWARD TO DISCUSS ALL
THESE I WHAT THE- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WITH. ALL OPEN IT UP
FOR MEN QUESTIONS THE-
REGARDING THE CHAIN THAT HAVE
IN COURT. INTO THE VERSION WAS
WITH SENATOR DORADO. THANK YOU
MADAM TO I JUST HAVE A QUESTION
FOR THE LA YOU ON THE R. AM CO
TAX. OF THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE SENATE AND THE LEGISLATURE.
WHAT IS THE IMPACT THROUGH THE
EFFECT OF NOT EXPLICITLY
INCLUDING ADJUSTMENTS TO THE TO
THE TAX WHAT WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN AS FAR AS. NGUYEN CLUED OR
NOVEL I AM NOT IT'S NOT VERY
CLEAR. OKAY WELL ALL MENTION
THAT AND THEN I'LL MY COLLEAGUE
MARK NEWTON- DESCRIBE IT IF HE
HAS A DISH CON. THAT'S IN THE
SAME PACK THE YOU CAN SEE
BEFORE THERE WOULD BE A- THERE
WOULD AND TO THE TAX THAT WOULD
GENERATE ADDITIONAL- REVENUE
AND RESULT IN A GENERAL FUND
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT BILLION
DOLLARS. AND THAT WAS A
PROVISION THAT WAS INCLUDED IN
THE- IN THE- SENATE REGIONAL
SENATE PACKAGE IN THE EVENT
THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL FUNDING
ON THE LEGISLATIVE WE AGREE.
PACKAGE DOESN'T JUST AS NOT AND
THIS FOR MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT. IT'S IS JUST AS MORE
APPROACH BE THE NCO TAP WOULD.
REQUIRE A TWO YOU KNOW IF.
FEDERAL CONSENT OR APPROVAL SO
IF REMOVES IT IN A CENTER
REMOVES THE RISK OF NOT RISK
FEDERAL GROUP FOR BY NODDING IT
AS A- AS A ISSUE PROVISION I
DON'T KNOW MARK A NEW. WOULD
HAVE ANY AND ADD TO THAT. A YES
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR IN AND
MEMBERS JUST MARK FROM THE OUT
JUST TO MY COLLEAGUE COMMENT
THERE. THE POTENTIAL TO PROVIDE
THEM CO TWO TO DOWN FEDERAL
FUNDS IS SUBJECT TO A FAIR BIT
OF ANSWER. BECAUSE THE
GOVERNMENT JUST FOR REVISING
THROUGH THE- THAT THAT THAT IN
FACT THROUGH MC TAX LIKE MY-
AND IN. THE RIVER THE RIVER
TACK AS WELL AS A THE KERR TAX
LIKE THE IN FROM UNDER THE NEW
RIGHT. SO THERE'S A TIE ISSUE
THOSE REGULAR ARE TO BE FINAL.
WITHIN THE NEXT MONTHS SO IF.
THE REVISED SORT OF HUMAN BEING
PRIOR TO THE- REGULATE TO BE A-
PROVISION. BUT IT UNLIKELY OR
THERE IS. A FAIR BIT OF THOSE
THE UNCERTAIN AND FOR OF THE
BILL OF THE OF THIS TO GET THE
RIVER. HOW RETURN FOR THE
BEFORE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THE RIGHT. STOKES AS MY CALL
MENTIONED THE. THAT THAT COULD
BE AVAILABLE THAT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS- SOMETIME IN THE FUTURE
OR- IS THAT ARE WE SAYING IT'S
NOT AVAILABLE ARE WE SAYING IT
COULD BE AVAILABLE I MEAN
EVERYTHING IS PRETTY UNCERTAIN.
SO THE HELPFUL BUT- I GUESS I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S- COULD BE
THERE. WE DON'T WANT IT TO BE
THERE WE DON'T WANT TO USE IT
OR DO WE WERE HOLDING THAT IN
CASE WE HAVE TO USE IT BECAUSE
A LOT OF THINGS THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING RIGHT. WE'RE
TRIGGERING IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES AND NOT IN OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES. I'M NOT SURE IF
THIS ONE BILLION. COULD BE
AVAILABLE OR IT'S JUST NOT
AVAILABLE. I CAN NOW PUT PROPS
COMMENT TO- TO THE MEMBER ON ON
THAT THAT QUESTION SO THE
BUDGET PACKAGE DOESN'T- ASSUME
THAT THAT THAT THE- THE STATE
WOULD BE PURSUING THAT OPTION.
SHOULD THE- SHOULD THE STATE'S
SORT OF WISH TO AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HASN'T THAT- HASN'T
CHANGED THE REGULATIONS YET IT
WOULD BE OPEN TO THE STATE TO
PURSUE AND- OUR- IF THE CURRENT
REGULATIONS THAT ARE
REGULATIONS WOULD APPLY WE DO
THINK THAT THERE IS THE
POTENTIAL. TO ACHIEVE ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS OF THE OF THE
DECISION OF GEERAL FUND
SAVINGS TO THE OPTION- IS NOT-
IS NOT ELIMINATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE BUDGET PACKAGE IS
JUST SIMPLY- NOT ASSUME THAT
THE- THE ADDITIONAL BE
ADDITIONAL- GENERAL FUND
SAVINGS WITH A CREW. I WOULD
ADD SENATOR DORADO JUST TO
REMIND US THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY PROPOSAL- DID NOT
FACTORY IN IN SEAL TAX- REVENUE
IF YOU WILL. WE HAD THE.
PROPOSAL AT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AWAITING APPROVAL
AND SO HE DIDN'T FACTORED IN-
CALL THE NINETEEN HITS AND IT'S
APPROVED AND SO AND SO WHAT THE
SENATE DID PASSED WAS WHAT WE
FELT WAS A MINOR ADJUSTMENT TO
THE PROPOSAL THAT WOULD FALL
WITH IN WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT APPROVED. THAT'S
WHAT THE SENATE APPROVED IN AS
YOU SEE AN AD WAS EXPLAINED BY
THE LA L. IN THE FINAL. TWO
PARTY DEAL- WE'VE TAKEN THAT
EXPLICIT ASSUMPTION OUT. HOW
CAN MEMBERS CAN RAISE THEIR
MINDS TO BE RECOGNIZE I SEE
DOCTOR PAN WHO WILL BE FOLLOWED
BY SENATOR MORE LAW. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- JUST WANTED TO
FIRST OF ALL. THANK YOU THANK
THE ASSEMBLY- FOR A WORKING
WITH THE SENATE'S IN-
DEVELOPING- THIS- JOINT
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE CONSIDERING I
BELIEVE- AND- MONDAY WHEN WE
PASSED THE BUDGET I JUST WANT
TO MAKE A COUPLE OF
OBSERVATIONS SO FIRST OF ALL ON
THE- COUNTY REALIGNMENT
ASSISTANCE- AS CHAIR OF BUDGET
SUB THREE YOU KNOW WE DEAL WITH
A LOT OF THE- SOCIAL SERVICE
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE GOING TO BE
EVEN GREATER DEMAND AS RESULT.
OF COVE IN NINETEEN AND
ECONOMIC IMPACT WITH PEOPLE
FORTUNATELY HAVING- LOST THEIR
JOBS AND- REQUIRING PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE A RECOGNIZING THAT A
PORTION OF THAT OF COURSE IS
ALSO BORN BUYER COUNTY SO WELL
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE STATE
BUDGET WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE
THAT ARE COUNTIES WHICH- UNDER
REALIGNMENT- WE'RE DEPENDENT ON
SALES TAX AND ANYONE IS. LOOK
AT WHAT'S HAPPENED TO US SALES
AND- DURING THE PANDEMIC
RECOGNIZE THOSE ARE WAY DOWN
VEHICLE LICENSE FEES AS WELL
WHICH OF COURSE OF YOU'D ANYONE
LOOKED AT A- GONE TO A CAR
DEALER WOULD RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT'S WAY DOWN AS WELL THAT WE
DO NEED TO STEP UP AND HELP
OUT. I WOULD THOUGH ALSO MAKE
NO WE ARE NOT MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS SO AS BUT I COUNTIES ARE
BALANCING THEIR BUDGETS AND
TRYING TO SERVE THE VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT PEOPLE WHO DO HAVE
NEEDS I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WOULD- HOPEFULLY ARE
COUNTIES WILL PRIORITIZE.
FUNDING FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IT WOULD BE A SHAME
IF DURING A PANDEMIC WE HAD
CUTS TO PUBLIC HEALTH WHILE WE
ARE TRYING TO FIGHT THIS
PANDEMIC AND- IT'S SO IT'S
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT- FOR OUR
COUNTIES EVEN AS THEY ARE ALSO
FACING THE ECONOMIC CHALLENGES
THAT WE ARE FACING IS A STATE.
THAT THEY PRIORITIZE ALSO
FUNDING PUBLIC HEALTH- AS
ACTUALLY THE LEADING PUBLIC
SAFETY AGENCY THEY SHOULD BE
SUPPORTING- TO DEAL JUST
ENDEMIC- SO I THINK AS WE LOOK
AT A REALIGNMENT ASSISTANCE I
HOPE THAT SOME OF THAT
ASSISTANCE BUT- WILL. ENSURE
THAT OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS- ARE SUSTAINED I
REALIZE THE SHOULD HOPEFULLY
GET ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING
AS WELL- WE HOPE OUR THAT WILL
HAPPEN BUT I. THAT WHAT WE
DON'T WANT TO DO SEE CUTS THE
PUBLIC HEALTH IS RESULT OF THAT.
DEMI THE OTHER THING OUT ALSO
MAKE NOTE AND I APPRECIATE
THAT- WE DO NEED OUR STATE
WORKERS TO HELP US OUT AS WERE
FACING THIS- BUDGET DEFICITS-
HERE. AS WELL BUT I WAS TO MAKE
NOTE THAT HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE WON THE LOWEST
RATIOS OF STATE WORKERS TO
POPULATION- WE'VE ASKED OUR
STATE WORKERS TO STEP UP. TO
HELP OUT TO ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE FILED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT AND
INTO THEIR STILL BACKLOGS BUT
WE'VE MOVED PEOPLE OVER TO DO
THAT. WE'RE ASKING STATE
WORKERS TO NOW BECOME CONTACT
TRACERS WITH THE GOVERNOR.
ANNOUNCING TEN THOUSAND-
CONTACT TRACERS BEING TRAINED.
SO EVEN AS WE ARE ASKING OUR
STATE WORKERS TO STEP UP. AND
DO THINGS. WE ARE ALSO IN ITALY
BECAUSE OF ARE. GOING TO BE
CHALLENGED IN TERMS OF- ALSO
POTENTIALLY TAKING. PAY CUTS AS
WELL SO. I APPRECIATE THAT OUR
PROPOSAL IS ASKING THAT THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS
MOVE FORWARD THAT WE HAVE A
NEGOTIATED APPROACH TO DOING
THIS. BUT I ALSO DO I STAND UP
AND SAY AND EXPRESS MY SUPPORT
FOR OUR STATE WORKERS. AS WELL
AS OUR COUNTY WORKERS WHO ARE.
ACTUALLY THEIR JOB DEMANDS ARE
GOING UP. THEY'RE GOING UP
BECAUSE OF THIS PANDEMIC
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY MORE
PEOPLE IN NEED. SO YOU KNOW WE
HAVE TO FACE THE REALITY OF.
OUR BUDGET AND WE HAVE TO PASS
A BALANCED BUDGET. BUT DIE
PRECIADO APPROACH AND I HOPE
THAT- IN THE FINAL NEGOTIATIONS
GOVERNOR'S. A NATION. OF THIS
FACT THAT. ARE AS OUR COUNTY
AND OUR STATE AFTER I NEED
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. YOU US MORE
LAW. BEING THANK YOU MATTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU FOR THE
OVERVIEW OF THE LEGISLATURE'S.
BUDGET PACKAGE I'M ASSUMING
THAT. THIS DOES NOT APPLY TO
OUR FIRST TWO. AGENDA ITEMS AB
SEVENTY FIVE AND SEVENTY SIX
BECAUSE- IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
OF. THE CURRENT YEAR'S BUDGET.
BUT IT DOES APPLY IT A LITTLE
BIT TO THE A. B. EIGHTY FIVE OR
THIRD ITEM. WHICH IS ONE OF
SEVERAL. OF THE BUDGET IS AT AS
WHEN I PLAY. THAT FOR THE
RECORD. GIVE ME ONE SECOND
THIRD MORE LONG. THROUGH HAND-SIGNALS ACROSS THE ROOM OUR
DIRECTOR OF THE SENATE BUDGET
THE DEPARTMENT SAYS THAT YOU
ARE CORRECT. THEN JUST- WANTED
ADDRESS MAYBE. A COMMENT YOU
MADE AT THE ON SET AND THAT WAS
SAID THAT THIS BUDGET. OVERALL
OF WOULD MINIMIZE HARMFUL CUTS
AND I'M JUST CURIOUS WHAT THAT
MEANS. MY POINT WAS IS THAT OUR
GOAL IS TO TRY TO- MINIMIZE
HARMFUL CUTS THE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS RECOGNIZING THE
IMPACT A PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC PANDEMIC HAS. DONE TO
OUR STATE BUT IT CERTAINLY IS
AN OUR GOAL TO PASS A BUDGET
THAT EXACERBATES HARM MY
STATEMENT WAS ALSO ON IN
REFERENCE TO THIS BUDGET IN
COMPARISON TO FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. THE PROPOSED MAY
REVISE THAT HAD A LONGER
TRIGGER LISTED HAD A TRIGGER
LIST OF CUTS THAT WOULD TO
AFFECTS SOONER JULY ONE VERSES
WHAT. ARE BUDGET BILL HAS
PROPOSED TO REALLY KIND OF FLIP
THE TRIGGER PROCESS- AND FUND
THE PROGRAMS UP UNTIL THE POINT
IF THE FEDERAL DOLLARS DON'T
COMMAND THEN WE HAVE THE PLAN
HOW TO BACK FILL IN OUR TRIGGER
LIST IS- SHORTER. SO THAT'S MY
POINT SO THEN ARE WE
ANTICIPATING A V. RECOVERY IT
JUST WHICH CAME DOWN LIKE ARE.
A BIG ROCK INTO A INTO THE LAKE
IS RESPECTING AT THE- TO COME
RIGHT BACK HIS WERE USING
RESERVES. AND ASSUMING REVENUES
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND IT WE'VE BEEN KIND OF ON AN
UPWARD TRAJECTORY SO WE'RE NOT.
LOOK I DON'T SEE. SOME KIND OF
TURN DOWN FOR THE FOR THE STATE
I JUST SEE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO IT. FOR THE WHAT WE CAN TO
KEEP THINGS IN PLACE FOR THIS
YEAR AND THEN WE CAN DISSIPATE
BUT THERE WERE THAT THE ECONOMY
JUST BOUNCES RIGHT BACK NO I.
HI NOR ANY OF US OF THIS
COMMITTEE- THAT NAIVE A SENATOR
MORE LOT- WE KNOW THAT THE LA
L. PRESENTED IN THEIR SPRING
FINANCE LETTER IT'LL TWO
VERSIONS AT EL AND A YOU
RECOVERY- MISTER PECK WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND AT ALL THIS AND
MORE LOT. EXPRESSED CONCERN.
YEAH I CAN SAY THAT- I THINK
THE E. YES AS- AS A MANAGER.
SAID WE DID PROVIDE A- SPRING
OUTLOOK WHICH INCLUDED A YOU IN
AN L. SHAPED SCENARIO. NON AYE
BUT I'M FAMILIAR WITH THAT.
YEAH MISTER REDDICK- THE MAYBE
I'LL ASK A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY
HAS THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PREPARED MULTI YEAR. BUDGETS TO
ASSUME WHAT WE CAN EXPECT IF WE
DON'T GT IT A QUICK ECONOMIC
REBOUND WHAT IF THIS IS. NOT OF
THE WHAT IF IT'S A HOCKEY STICK
LIKE THE GREAT RECESSION WHERE
WE HAD. A MASSIVE DROP AND THEN
IT JUST WS SUCH A SLOW SLOW
LONG CLIMB OUT. I AM JUST.
WONDERING IF FOR. I'M CONCERNED
MAYBE WORK WE'RE DEPLETING ALL
OF OUR RESERVES AND HAVING. A
ROW A MAYBE A HIGHER. WEIGHT ON
FEDERAL FUNDING THEN WE SHOULD
BE HAVING A WE'RE NOT
ANTICIPATING PROPERLY FUTURE
YEAR TRENDS AND THAT'S- WHAT
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT. MAYBE MR
PRESS ONE IF ON. MIGHT BE ABLE
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION MADAM
CHAIR. YEAH. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND THANK YOU SENATOR
MORE LOCK ON AT THE QUESTION
THAT YOU RAISE TYPICALLY THAT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND I
GUESS WHAT YOU WOULD CALL MORE
NORMAL TIMES WE HAVE ARE
EXPECTED SCENARIO AND THEN WE
HAVE RECESSION SCENARIO SASUKE
SO TWO POSSIBLE WAYS IN WHICH
THINGS CAN GO OF COURSE IN THIS
SITUATION BY THE TIME WE PUT
OUT OUR MAY REVISIONS FORECASTS
THE ECONOMY WAS ALREADY IN
RECESSION SO WHILE WE DON'T
HAVE SPECIFIC. DIFFERENT
SCENARIOS OF THE WAY THAT
RECESSION CAN GO OUR ECONOMIC
TEAM CERTAINLY LOOKED AT THAT
AND WHAT THEY HAVE PROPOSED IS
BASICALLY WHAT THEY VIEW AS THE
MOST LIKELY SCENARIO GIVEN ALL
THE FACTORS RELATED TO THE PACE
OF RE OPENING ACTIONS BY THE
FEDERAL RESERVE THE LATEST
UNEMPLOYMENT DATA SO HOLD
REFLECTED IN OUR ECONOMICS IN
THERE AND YOUR POINT ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITIES- THE ECONOMIC A
SAX- THIS RECESSION AND THE
COMMON NINETEEN PANDEMIC GOING
ON FROM SOMETIMES YOU CAN SEE
IN OUR OUR WORK THAT WE DO. SEE
SOME PRETTY SIGNIFICANT. ACTS
NOT ONLY THE NEXT YEAR BUT OVER
THE MEAT TERM AND SO VALUES THE
REVENUE THAT WE ARE PROJECTING.
DON'T MATCH THE REVENUE THAT WE
PROJECTED THIS TIME A YEAR AGO
FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND WHEN IT
COMES BASICALLY TO THE RESEARCH
THAT YOU MENTIONED. IN THE NAY
REVISION WE DIDN'T ANTICIPATE
THAT FEDERAL FUNDING WE KNOW
THAT HOW THAT WILL ULTIMATELY
BE REFLECT. IN THE FINAL BUDGET
WILL BE THE RESULT THAT
WHATEVER THREE PARTY AGREEMENT
TIMES BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY IN
THE SENATE BUT CERTAINLY IN OUR
PLAN- THE BUDGET STABILIZATION
ACT. OUT AS WELL AS THE STATE'S
NEVER SERVED IN OTHER RESERVES
THOSE WERE TO BE DRAWN DOWN
OVER A PERIOD OF THREE YEARS
RECOGNIZING BACKS IT IS LIKELY
THAT EVEN IF WE MAKE A
RELATIVELY. QUICKER RECOVERY
THAT SOME PEOPLE ARE EXPECTING
WE DO EXPECT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO SEE THE EFFECTS OF
THIS RECESSION FOR SOME PERIOD
OF TIME. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THE THOROUGH INSTRUMENT
MAYBE AS A FOLLOW UP- YOUR
INCLUDING. TAX REVENUE. AS
FROM. NINE MILLION OVER THREE
YEARS BY MIND NINE BILLION
SKEWS ME- I WAS UNDER THE
IMPRESSION THAT WE WOULDN'T BE
RAISING TAXES BUT THE ONE
EXAMPLE IN IN TODAY'S AGENDA
UNDER A. B. EIGHTY FIVE IS THAT
WE WOULD. NOT ALLOW THE
UTILIZATION OF NET OPERATING
LOSSES FOR THE NEXT THREE
YEARS. BEING AS A FORMER
SWELLED. BEING A CERTIFIED
PUBLIC ACCOUNTANT ACTIVE- YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE HIT NUMBER BY
A LOCK DOWN OF THE ECONOMY. AND
SO NOW THEY'RE NOT. CREATING
REVENUES IN. THEY'RE GONNA HAVE
LOSSES AND THE ONE WAY TO KIND
OF RECOVER FROM THAT IS TO
CARRY THIS FORWARD AND BENEFIT
FROM THOSE DEDUCTIONS AND SO
NEVER HITTING A SECOND TIME
WHEN THE ECONOMY WAS SHUT DOWN.
BY THE CITY AND I'M JUST
WONDERING WHY WE WOULD TAKE
THAT KIND OF APPROACH AS
OPPOSED TO TRYING TO HELP
BUSINESSES RECOVER AND THEN
THEY WOULD GENERATE MORE
BUSINESS MORE ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
IN THEIR FORMALLY TAX REVENUE.
YES ON THAT ISSUE ALL SPEAK
BRIEFLY TO IT I ALSO HAVE A G.
CHAMBERLAIN ON THE LINE AND I
KNOW I ALSO WANT TO DEFER TO
THE CHAIR- WHY NO- THAT BILL IS
A LITTLE BIT LATER ON THE
AGENDA BUT ALSO VERY QUICKLY.
TWO POINTS ON THAT POINT I
THINK THE FIRST IS THAT WE VERY
MUCH VIEW THIS AS A TEMPORARY-
AND THAT THIS WOULD BE SPURRED
THIS CALENDAR YEAR AND THE NEXT
TWO CALENDAR YEARS AND PEOPLE
WHO HAVEN'T HEARD THOSE LOSSES
IN THE PAST WOULD BE ABLE TO
USE THEM AFTER THAT AND IF ANY
OF THOSE CREDITS- WERE TO BE
EXPIRING IN THIS TIME PERIOD-
THOSE THAT OPERATING LOSSES
WOULD CARRY OVER FOR AN
EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME-
BECAUSE OF THE SUSPENSION. THE
SECOND POINT IS THAT THAT THIS
IS VERY MUCH A TEMPORARY
MEASURE- MEASURES SOMEWHAT
SIMILAR TO THIS HAVE BEEN
TAKING IN PREVIOUS RECESSIONS
AND GIVEN THAT THE PRESSURES
THAT WERE UNDER WE'RE HOPING
THAT EVERYONE CAN STEP FORWARD
IN A VERY TEMPORARY WAY AND
THEN. WHAT HAS TO RECOVERY WAS
ON- THOSE AT THESE NET
OPERATING LOSS IS THE ABILITY
TO USE THAT WILL BE RESTORED
AND THEN THE THIRD POINT I'LL
MAKE FINALLY IS THAT. THE
WEEPING COLLUDED A SPECIFIC
PROVISION IN OUR SO THAT THIS
WOULD ONLY BE FOR TAXPAYERS AT
WITH. ABOUT ONE DOLLARS WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT VERY SMALL
BUSINESSES MOM AND POP TYPE
ENTERPRISES DAY WOULD NOT BE
PROHIBITED FROM USING THESE
THAT OPERATE LOSSES THIS YEAR
OR NEXT TO USE. OR ENTITIES
THAT HAVE A BOB THE ONLY OR IS
TO DO IT THAT IS OUR NEW
BROUGHT BY CREAM IT I THE- CAN
SUSPEND THEM USING LOSSES JUST
THIS. SPORT AND THEN AS- BRAD
ECONOMY RECOVERS. ABOUT RENTALS
WILL BE ABLE TO USE CREDITS YOU
CAN USE SO I GUESS I JUST WANT
TO BE IN BUT THAT TO OUR TAX.
CAN THEY PAY ARE SALARIES IT'S
THEIR HARD WORK AND ARE MAKE
THE HARM CAT. AND IT WOULD BE
HELP. THAT THEY SEE THAT IT'S A
SHARED. THAT MAYBE WE DO NEED
TO ALSO MAY SOME HARMFUL CUTS
AND THAT IT DOESN'T ALWAYS. ON
THE SHOULDERS OF OUR TAXPAYERS
AND THAT'S JUST AN OBSERVATION
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
EIGHT AND TO BE CLEAR ARE YOU
NOT I GUESS IN MY MIND I DON'T
YOU KNOW SEPARATE THE TWO THOSE
WHO- ARE ARE LOOKING TO
UTILIZE- THE STATE PROGRAMS-
OUR TAXPAYERS TO. AND SO I
THINK WE NEED TO JUST BE CLEAR
THAT IT'S NOT ONE GROUP VERSUS
ANOTHER. THEY TO OUR TAXPAYERS
AND THEY CONTRIBUTE TO THE
GENERAL FUND AND BECAUSE OF
THIS PANDEMIC ARE GOING TO NEED
TO RELY ON THE SUPPORT FROM THE
STATE. IT'S NOT TWO DIFFERENT
GROUPS OF PEOPLE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE LET'S MOVE ON TO
SENATOR STERN. AT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND- TO THE TO THE
STAFF FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK
AND A COMPLETELY COMPRESSED
TIME FRAME- I FIRST JUST WANTED.
WHOLEHEARTEDLY ENDORSE THE
SENATE'S APPROACHING THE
CREATIVITY AND THE REFUSAL TO
ACCEPT- CONSTRAINTS OF CERTAIN
TIMING ON TRIGGERS HERE AND
REALLY TRY TO SET OUR OWN PACE
AND HOPEFULLY WASHINGTON STEPS
UP BUT I THINK WE'VE GOT A
REALLY TERRIBLE FRAMEWORK TO
INTO OUR POLITICAL IMPASSE
THAT. I WORRY WILL AMOUNT- TO
THE U. S. SENATE FAILING TO ACT.
I WOULD JUST WANTED TO ASK A
SPECIFIC QUESTION THE WILD FIRE
SUPPLEMENTS I NOTICED THAT WAS
ONE OF THE KEY PROVISIONS IN AB
SEVENTY FIVE BEFORE US. AND I
IN TERMS OF TAKING CARE OF OUR
OUR STATE AND COUNTY WORKERS
AND THE PEOPLE WHO DO THE HARD
WORK TO DO WITH OUR CRISES.
APPRECIATE THAT THE BACKUP FOR
BOTH OUR FOLKS A CAL FIRE AS
WELL AS DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES WHO WERE. DOING THESE
CRITICAL- RESPONSE CHECKS WHEN
THE POWER WENT DOWN. HSS AND
ALL OUR SOCIAL WORKERS HAD TO
GO TO WORK AND MAKE SURE THE
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS-
THAT WE DIDN'T LOSE THEM IN THE
PROCESS- I NOTICED THOUGH A- A
SUPPLEMENT OF I THINK TWENTY
FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION. A TWO
CARILLO YES- I WAS WONDER IF WE
GET A LITTLE MORE DETAIL. ON
THAT ITEM. WELL IT. REGARDING
IS THIS IT THIS IS THE IT LOOKS
TO BE SORT OF BACK FILL FOR
ACTIVITY COSTS THAT HAVE
ALREADY OCCURRED. BUT DO WE
ALSO A FORWARD LOOKING BUDGET
ITEM HERE. OR IS THIS JUST.
SORT OF A BACK FILL OF PAST
COSTS AND THEN WE REALLY DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING. GOING AHEAD FOR
THIS P. S. P. S. SEASON COMING
UP. SENATOR STERN I THINK ON.
THAT PARTICULAR QUESTION ALL
ASK IF MY COLLEAGUE- BRIAN
BROWN COULD WEIGH IN WITH. SOME
SOME ADDITIONAL INSIGHT. IN
MISTER BROWN BEFORE YOU BEGIN
MEMBERS I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
YOU THAT THIS POINT WERE ASKING
QUESTIONS OF THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE BILL WE'RE GOING TO
GET INTERNET INDIVIDUAL
PRESENTATIONS ON EACH TRAILER
BILL MAY WE DIFFER THAN MY
QUESTION WILL JUST ACCEPT MY
STATEMENTS A COMMON. GUT AND
I'LL COME BACK TO THE TO
RELOCATE WOMAN THANK YOU MY
APOLOGIES ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ON THE OVERALL- ON DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE SENATE AND LET'S
SAY THE PACKAGE MR STERN ANY
QUESTIONS ON THAT. NO JUST A
GOOD LUCK WE HOPE WISH YOU WELL
THIS WEEKEND THANK YOU SIR
SENATOR NIELSEN YOUR MICROS UP
AGAIN THESE ARE QUESTIONS ON-
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
SENATE VERSION AND THE NEW
LEGISLATIVE AGREEMENT. THE IS
IT POSSIBLE THIS IS A QUESTION
MISTER PECK IS IT POSSIBLE THAT
IN THAT WE'RE NOT DEALING TOO
MUCH WITH THE STRUCTURAL
DEFICITS IN THIS BUDGET THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE AN
EXACERBATED PROBLEM IN THE
FUTURE AS WE MOVE AHEAD.
SENATOR NEAL SAID I THINK THAT-
CERTAINLY IT IS POSSIBLE ARE
OUT LOOKING COLLUDED THAT AND I
BELIEVE- THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ALSO ESTIMATED THAT
THERE S A STRUCTURAL COMPONENT
TO THE BUDGET PROBLEM THIS YEAR.
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE DO NOT
EXPERIENCE A RECOVERY- NOTE
THERE IS SOMEWHAT GREATER USAGE
OF SOME OF THE STATE'S ONE TIME
RESOURCES IN THE PACKAGE THAT
WE'RE- CONSIDERING HERE TODAY
AND IN THE EVENT THERE IS NOT
A- YOU CAN N IT RECOVERY. OVER
THE COURSE OF THE NEXT TWELVE
MONTHS OR SO. IT'S LIKELY THAT.
ADDITIONAL ONGOING SOLUTIONS
WOULD NEED TO BE CONSIDERED- SO
THAT SOMETHING FOR ORDER I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE TO KEEP
IN MIND. WELL I PERSONALLY AM
CONFIDENT WE'RE GOING TO SEE A
RECOVERY IT'S NOT GOING TO BE A
STEEP ONE BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE A- SLIGHTLY IN PLANNING ONE
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
BOUNCING BACK. BETTER WE WOULD
CERTAINLY HOPE SO. BUT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT DOES LOOM OUT
THERE AND A LOT OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE NOW IS GOING TO BE
PREDICATED ON A RESURGENCE OF
THE ECONOMY. AND REVENUES THERE
FROM. AT. THANK YOU SIR SENATOR
BAIL. MADAM CHAIR. I WOULD LIKE
TO US ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE ON
THE- REALIGNMENT FUNDS THAT
IT'S- INDICATED- FOUR HUNDRED.
I THINK IT'S FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. SENSE I WAS
INVOLVED IN THE REALIGNMENT AND
TWENTY OF TWENTY ELEVEN. AND
THE REALIGNMENT AND TWENTY
ELEVEN GAVE A PRIMACY IN THE
ALLOCATION FORMULA A STELLAR
SAID TIME TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND IT. PUT TO THE GROWTH
FACTORS YEAH THE ATEGORY OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT I DON'T
REALLY SEE IN THE OTHER
CATEGORIES. AND THE QUESTION I
HAVE IS AFTER TEN YEARS AND
AFTER ALL THE CHANGES IN PUBLIC
SAFETY SOCIAL SERVICE MENTAL
HEALTH AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT.
THE HORRIBLE CUTBACKS IN HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES THAT WE HAVE
IN THIS YEAR'S. ISN'T IT TIME
TO RE LOOK AT THOSE FORMULAS OR
LEASE LAYOUT COUNTIES TO HAVE
SOME. FLEXIBILITY IN THE SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS THAT- WE HAVE
IN THE TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT. A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
MY DISTRICT ARE. SCREAMING
ABOUT HOW. THEY DON'T WANT THEY
WANT CHANGES IN POLICE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND I THINK WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO RE LOOK
AT THE REALIGNMENT FUNDS AND
MAKE SOME SUBSTANTIAL
CONTRIBUTION. TO WHAT I
CONSIDER TO BE A PROGRESSIVE-
APPROPRIATE AND IN THE INTEREST
OF PUBLIC SAFETY AND INNER
ANSWERS OF OUR HUMAN BEINGS IN
OUR IN OUR STATE. THAT WILL
OTHERWISE LOSE SERVICES. AND
MENTAL HEALTH. SOCIAL SERVICE
FOSTER CARE IN OTHER CATEGORIES
SO I THINK. IT'S TIME TO RE
LOOK. AT THE PROCESS AND TIMING
OF THE FORMULA THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY ELEVEN.
SO OLD FORMULA THERE'S A LOT OF
LAWS AND BEEN STRANGERS THE
INITIATIVE IS A LOT OF CHANGE
IN OUR SOCIETY. WE SHOULD
REALLY LOOK AT IT. AND HAVE A
LOOK AT IT OVER THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS. BECAUSE RIGHT NOW.
THERE'S HORRIBLE CUTBACKS
THEY'RE PROBABLY GONNA RESULT
IN MANY. PROGRAMS TO BE CLOSE
TO HUMAN SERVICES. SO WELL WE
HAVE THIS FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. IN REALIGNMENT I WOULD
I WOULD URGE THAT. IN SOME WAY
WE LOOK AT THE REALIGNMENT
PROGRAM. TO REACH US NOT NOT
ADD TO THE SPENDING BUT LOOK AT
THE SPENDING THAT WERE WORSE
OUR SPENDING THAT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS. AND POSSIBLY REALIGN
THE MONEY TWO MORE IMPORTANT
PRIORITIES THAT THE COMMUNITIES
OF TODAY HAVE VERSES TEN YEARS
AGO THANK YOU. THANK YOU WOULD
FINANCE ARE LA L. LIKE TO
ACCOMMODATE ALL. I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD TO ENSURE HER
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU IT IN JUST
A CLEAR FINE LOOKING AT THE
ALEJO'S CHART- SENATOR BILL THE
FOUR HUNDRED WOULD BE IN THE
EVENT THAT THERE WERE. WE WERE
NOT ABLE TO SECURE FEDERAL
FUNDING WE HOPE TO INCREASE
THAT AMOUNT BEYOND WHAT THE
SENATE APPROVED AT SIX HUNDRED
MILLION TO TAKE IT UP TO THE
BILLION BUT AGAIN THE FOUR
HUNDRED IS IN THE EVENT THAT
THERE- WE RECEIVED NO FEDERAL
FUNDING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS PER SHARE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
SENATOR SKINNER. I WANTED TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE THAT- MY
COLLEAGUE ON SEVEN FIVE BUDGET
SUBFOSSIL. WE OBVIOUSLY IN SUB
FIVE IS WAS IT A FIVE AS HIS
BRAIN PRESENTED TO US THIS WAS
NOT THE INCREASE TO- DEALING
WITH THE- THE- BACK FILL OF
REALIGNMENT WAS NOT ADDRESSED
WE DID NOT HEAR IT WHEN WE HAD
OUR SAID. AND EVEN IF WE HAD I
WILL BE HONEST JUST BECAUSE OF
THE CONDENSED NATURE THAT ALL
OF US HAD TO EXPERIENCE WE
WOULD NOT HAVE GOTTEN INTO THE
GREAT DETAIL. THOUGH I THINK
THAT NOT TO SAY I THINK. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE'S
POINTS HAVE MERIT THAT WE HAVE
MADE GREAT CHANGES TO OUR TO
MANY OPERATIONS AND POLICIES
REGARDING. CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
THAT WHILE REALIGNMENT WAS A
VERY SIGNIFICANT POLICY THAT WE
ADOPTED. WE IN EFFECT WE IS THE
LEGISLATURE LET GO OF OUR
ABILITY TO HAVE MORE OVERSIGHT-
AUTHORITY NOT OVERSIGHT WE
ALWAYS CAN HAVE OVERSIGHT
AUTHORITY OVER THE EXPENDITURE
OF THOSE FUNDS WHICH WE PROVIDE
TO THE COUNTIES. AND WE HAVE
NOT HAD A SAY FOR EXAMPLE A
DETAILED HEARING ON HOW THEIR
PRACTICES NOW ME A LINE OR NOT
A LINE WITH. I DO IT
TRANSPORTATION- POLICIES THAT
THE STATE HAS ENACTED. AND WE
HAVE AN EFFECT REMOVED
OURSELVES FROM THE ABILITY TO.
ARE REALLY- EITHER TAKE BACK OR
OR DIRECT THOSE FUNDS BY THE
WAY THE ORIGINAL LEGISLATION
WAS WRITTEN SO TO INCREASE THEM
RIGHT NOW WHILE IT MAY BE
APPROPRIATE I THINK IT IT DOES.
NOT NECESSITATE A REAL HEARING
AND PERHAPS AND ASKED TO LA- TO
EVALUATE. WHAT THESE DIFFERENT
CHANGES HAVE BEEN HAVE MADE
SINCE REALIGNMENT AND WAYS THAT
WE MIGHT POTENTIALLY RE LOOK OR
RESTRUCTURING ALIGNMENT SO THAT
IT IS OPTIMAL FOR ALL OF THE
OBJECTIVES THAT WE HAVE SO I
JUST WANT TO RAISE THAT IT IS
NOT ALL THAT ISBEFORE US BUT
GIVEN THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT. A FOUR HUNDRED MILLION-DOLLAR POTENTIAL EXPENDITURE IT
IS SIGNIFICANT AND UNDER THE
CURRENT THE WAY THE- ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION WAS WRITTEN
WOULDN'T REALLY ALLOW US TO
HAVE ANY FOR ANY FURTHER STORY
OVER THOSE FUNDS IF WE PROVE
THEM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
TO SKINNER CENTER NIELSEN I SEE
YOUR MIKE IS BACK UP OKAY THANK
YOU A FOLLOW UP MADAM CHAIR TO
MY COLLEAGUES FROM BERKELEY AND
THE SENATOR VALLEY ON
REALIGNMENT. THERE'S A PORTION
OF THIS BUDGET THAT IS RELATED
TO CONTINUING REALIGNMENT OF
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND MAYBE HAVE MISTER VISION
NOT THAN OR SOMEONE IN HIS TEAM
COULD COMMENT. ONE OF THE
FAILURES OF REALIGNMENT IS THAT
WE- FITTED TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
A LOT OF THE AUTHORITIES THAT
THE STATE HAD FORMALLY ACCEPTED.
BUT I WOULD ARGUE WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT FUNDING FOR THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO MEET THAT
TEST IN IN THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL. THERE IS A
REALIGNMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
THAT REMAINS THE REST OF WHAT
IS AN WAS THE YOUTH AUTHORITY
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. BUT AS I
LOOKED AT THE FIGURES AND I
THINKTHAT THERE WERE SOME OF
LIKE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
SAVINGS THAT WAS ATTRIBUTED
MAYBE THEY CAN. ACTIVELY DETECT
THOSE FIGURES. BUT WHEN WE
LOOKED IN THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT WAS GOING TO BE
TRANSFERRED TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TO MAINTAIN THAT RESPONSIBILITY
THAT WAS NOW BEING AS SOON BY
THEM THERE WAS A GREAT
DISCREPANCY. AND PROBABLY
UNDERSTATED BECAUSE THE MISSION
OF THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
IS ALL REHABILITATION THAT
REQUIRES A LOT MORE EXPENSIVE
REHABILITATIVE RESOURCES AT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL TO
ACCOMMODATE THIS POPULATION.
SETTLEMENT MAYBE FINANCE COULD
THE COMMENT ON THAT DISCREPANCY
AND HOW THEY SEE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WILL BE ABLE TO
ASSUME THIS BURDEN TO HOUSE AND
TO REHABILITATE THOSE
PARTICULAR. WHAT WERE FORMALLY
CALLED WARDS. MR THIS ONE OFTEN
ON YOU OR ONE OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES. YES I'LL SPEAK I
DON'T HAVE MY COLLEAGUES WHO
SPECIALIZE- ON THOSE ISSUES
THAT DIRECTLY ON THE LINE RIGHT
NOW ALL CD RE BRIEFLY THAT WE
HAD INCLUDED A NUMBER OF
ASSUMPTIONS IN THE NAY REVISION
BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT OUR TEAM
IS AN ACTIVE CONVERSATIONS ON
THIS ISSUE IN PARTICULAR- WITH
LEGISLATIVE STAFF IN TERMS OF
WHAT WILL BE REFLECTED. IN A
THREE PARTY AGREEMENTS SO UP
CHINA WILL LAST ALL BUT YOU AND
I KNOW THOSE CONVERSATIONS
INCLUDING ON SOME ISSUES THAT
YOU RAISED ARE HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS BEFORE WE MOVE INTO
HEARING FROM FINANCE ON EACH OF
THE TRAILER BILLS. INDIVIDUALLY.
SEEN NONE OF A WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM. GOING TO START WITH
THE FIRST TRAILER BILL FOURTH
AB SEVENTY FIVE THE
SUPPLEMENTAL APPROPRIATIONS
BILL I'D NOTE THAT- FINANCE
WILL PRESENT THE BILLS AND THEN
BE ON HAND ALONG WITH ELLIE- TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ON THE
SERVICE WHEN NOTHING CAN YOU
START PLEASE WITH DESCRIBING.
THE FIRST TRAILER AB FIVE. YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SERVICE FIRST BILL IS AB
SEVENTY FIVE AND THIS IS A
SUPPLEMENTAL APPROPRIATIONS
BILL FOR THE CURRENT YEAR WITH
THAT WERE IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY. AND THIS IS FOR.
COSTS BEYOND THE RESOURCES THAT
WERE PROVIDED IN THE TWENTY
NINE TEAMS BUDGET ACT- SO
THERE'S SEVERAL DIFFERENT
EXPENDITURES- IN THIS TALE-
THEY ADDED TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS. I
WILL JUST DESCRIBE A COUPLE OF
THEM AND THEN HAPPY TO TAKE-
ANY QUESTIONS ON THAT SO FIRST-%
AS CENTER STORE MENTIONED THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF EXPENDITURES IN
HERE IN TERMS OF AN ANTICIPATED
COSTS RELATED TO WILDFIRES
INCLUDING BOTH THE CAMPFIRE
FROM TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AS WELL
AS TWENTY NINETEEN WILD FIRES
AND RELATED PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFF A SENSE OF COMMUNITY
RESILIENCY AND SO ALSO
SPECIFICALLY I JUST BECAUSE
SENATOR STERN HAD. HIGHLIGHTED
THE SPECIFIC POINT- WHEN IT
COMES TO THE TWENTY FOUR
MILLION FOR A WE ASKED. THAT
WAS A COMBINATION OR THAT IS A
COMBINATION PASSED ADDITIONAL
COPS AT THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER AND REGIONAL CENTERS OUR
TASK BY WE ASK FOR. RESPONDING
TO PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF
THE BENCH BUT ALSO FOR THE
RESPONSES TO THE WILD FIRES
THEMSELVES AND THIS INCLUDES-
FIRE RESPOND TO IS. FOR THE
STATE FOR REIMBURSEMENTS TO
OTHER JURISDICTIONS AND LOCAL
ENTITIES THAT ARE OUTSIDE THE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM THAT THAT WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA. AS WELL AS
REIMBURSEMENT FOR OTHER STATES
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA. FOR THE
MUTUAL AID THAT WE DO HAVE WITH
THAT SO WHEN THEY ARE COMING
IN. TO HELP US. AND THIS IS
SIMILAR TO HOW. YEAH STATE SIX
THREE. OUR MUTUAL A AGREEMENTS
ONE GOING TO HELP OTHERS. I'M
SURE THERE NUMBER DIFFERENT AND
THAT'S ONE OF THEM RELATED TO
BUT THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY NINETEEN WILDFIRE SEASON
AND WE KNOW THAT SOME OF THESE
EXPENSES. COSTA SCHOOL YEARS WE
WENT THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
LOOKING TO MAXIMIZE
REIMBURSEMENT BUT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'VE DONE IN OUR CONTINUING TO
DO. SO THESE ARE EXPENDITURES
TECHNICAL OUR GENERAL SIGN ON
TOP OF WHATEVER REIMBURSEMENTS
THAT WERE ABLE TO RISK. THERE
AND BURR ODDS ABA. ARE OTHER
MANDATE SPENDING- THAT WE
BELIEVED WAS IMPORTANT OR
NECESSARY TO INCLUDE IN THIS
STILL UNCLEAR. SHE'S RELATED TO
CDC ARE OPERATED SOME CAL FIRE
EXPENDITURES FOR A SETTLEMENT
THAT COULD NOT BE STORED WITH
EXISTING RESOURCES AS WELL AS
CDSA AND THE STAIRS I'M SO
THEIR NUMBER DIFFERENT ISSUES
HERE- THEY CROSS NUMBER OF
UNITS I'M HAPPY TO HELP WITH
ANY QUESTIONS THAT I CAN AND IF
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT I CAN
ANSWER DIRECTLY HERE. ALL MAKES
TO GET BACK TO YOUR OFFICE AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE. THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN ANY FOLLOW UP TO
THE- I APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION AT AND I'M I'M
JUST WONDERING SINCE WE SORT OF
HAD. THE SORT OF ON
UNANTICIPATED OVERAGES OR MAYBE
A GAP IN OUR ABILITY TO GET
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT DO WE AND
WE ANTICIPATE THE SAME ISSUE
COMING AGAIN THIS THIS COMING
P. S. P. S. SEASON. JUST
WONDERING HOW WE SORT OF DONE
THE FUTURE ANTICIPATION ACOSTA.
YES BASICALLY ON DAYS WHEN IT
COMES TO THE YEAR TO CALM EVEN
THOUGH A NUMBER OF AREAS OF THE
BUDGET- WE PROPOSED CUTS FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACTS.
FOR PS PS OUR COMMUNITY POWER
RESILIENCY WERE INCLUDING
ANOTHER SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR AD THAT ANTICIPATED
EXPENDITURES IT'S OF COURSE
IMPOSSIBLE TO SAY WHETHER
THAT'S GOING TO BE SUFFICIENT.
TO COVER THESE TYPES OF
EXPENSES IT DEPENDS ON WHAT
KIND OF WILDFIRE SEASON THAT WE
HAVE. BUT THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
INCLUDING THE BUDGET AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE HE'S AN EVEN
AS WE WERE SCRUTINIZIG. EVERY
AREA OF THE BUDGET THAT WE DID
INCLUDE THAT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THAT POSSIBILITY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION AND I WOULD JUST
URGE IN THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THAT BUDGET. FOR BOTH LOCAL AND
STATE EXPENDITURES THAT. WE
DON'T JUST RELY ON DIESEL POWER
GOING FORWARD WE THOUGHT WE SAW
SOMEWHAT DISAPPOINTING DECISION
FROM THE P. YOU SEE YESTERDAY
AUTHORIZING- AND ALL THESE ALL
APPROACH. FOR THE P. JEANNIE
TERRITORY FOR MEETING THIS
SEASON'S. A P. S. P. S. ISSUES
AND I'M I'M JUST HOPING THE
STATE CAN TRY TO BE. A BIT
PROGRESSIVE AND REALLY TRY TO
EXHAUST ALL ARE CLEAN ENERGY
OPTIONS FIRST IN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR THE INDULGENCE AND THANK
YOU MISTER VISWANATHA ON FOR
YOUR YOUR DILIGENCE HERE. THANK
YOU SENATOR NIELSEN FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR Y. KOWSKI. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- BUT I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR THE FIRE
RESPONSE TO THAT TRAGIC FIRE ON
PARADISE AND THE RICH IN BUTTE
COUNTY. THE BEEN VERY ATTENTIVE
TO US UP THERE AND VERY HELPFUL
TO US AND I CAN ATTEST TO THAT
THE COMMUNITY IS COMING BACK.
THE TRAGEDY REMAINS AT THAT
COMMUNITY. FORMALLY WAS TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND. AND POPULATION
IT IS NOW SEVEN. AND MAY BE
DECLINING. AND AS PART OF THAT
ISSUE. THERE IS THE SECOND YEAR
FUNDING FOR THE- MAINTENANCE OF
THE PARADISE IRRIGATION
DISTRICT. AND I THANK BOTH THE
FIT IS A WILL ASSEMBLY DID NOT
ACT NOR DID THE SENATE FILL IT
LOOKS LIKE THAT SECOND YEAR
FUNDING WILL BE PROVIDED THE
POINT THAT I MUST MAKE
REGARDING THAT. IF IT IS NOT
PROVIDED. THAT DISTRICT. WILL
COLLAPSE. AND THAT IS THE WATER
SUPPLY FOR THE WHOLE AREA UP
THERE AND WITHOUT WATER THEY
CANNOT COME BACK IN FACT THE
SEVEN THOUSAND POPULATION WILL
EVEN DIMINISH SO IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AND I WOULD ENTREAT
US TO KEEP AN EYE THAT THAT
DOES HAVE THE SECOND YEAR
FUNDING TO KEEP THAT IRRIGATION
DISTRICT GOING WELL IT THEN
ENDS UP HOPING TO. HAVE SOME
MORE CUSTOMERS. AND ALSO TO
THANK. THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR FOR SENSITIVITY TO OUR
COUNTY FAIRS. PEOPLE LOOK AT
THE FAIRS ARE JUST A WONDERFUL
ENTERTAINMENT AND SUMMER. BUT
THESE FACILITIES ARE USED YEAR
ROUND BUT MOST PARTICULARLY
THEY ARE USED FOR DISASTERS AS
STAGING AREAS FOR AIR DISASTERS
THERE WAS A CONSIDERATION. LAST
YEAR TO. MAKE THESE FACILITIES
AVAILABLE FOR HOUSING HOMELESS
POPULATIONS AND I ARGUED VERY
VOCIFEROUSLY AGAINST THAT
BECAUSE IF THERE ARE HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AND RESIDING. WE
CANNOT REMOVE THEM WHEN YOU
HAVE A CRISIS AS WE OFTEN DO
WITH FIRES AND FLOODS THE
CHATTER OF EARTH QUAKES TO
THESE ARE STAGING AREAS SO THAT
PART OF THE BUDGET IS VERY
WELCOMING VERY APPRECIATE.
THANK YOU A MOVING ON TO
SENATOR WORK ASKING. OF SERVICE
MR THIS WAY OFF AND FINANCE HI
I THINK I WILL RESPECTFULLY.
NOT DISAGREE BUT SEPARATE
MYSELF FROM THE- THE GENTLEMAN
FROM- TO HAMMOCK COUNTY IS I
SEE THAT AB SEVENTY FIVE IS
JUST. ATRUE UP THIS IS LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET AT THIS CURRENT
YEAR'S BUDGET AND WE WERE SHORT
ON FIRE FUNDS WE HAD TO
REIMBURSE- BUT THE FORTY
MILLION OR FORTY POINT THREE
MILLION FROM GENERAL FUND SITS.
THIS COULD GO TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF THE NAGRA CULTURE. IS SIMPLY
GO TO PAY FOR CLOSING DOWN THE
FAIRS THROUGH JUNE OF THIS YEAR
I MEAN THE FINANCE IN THE CASE
THAT THE FEARS OF LOS NINETY
EIGHT MILLION THROUGH THIS
FISCAL YEAR. AND A GOOD TO
GIVEN FORTY THREE MILLION
BECAUSE I GUESS THAT'S WHAT THE
STATE'S. ANSWER IS BUT PLAN AS
I UNDERSTAND IT IS AT ALL THE
MANAGERS ARE MERELY FIRE FROM
ALL THE- SEVENTIES FAIRS. NEXT
MONTHS WILL BE TO GET RID OF
ALL THE IN THE EIGHTIES. AND
THERE'S NO. SUGGESTION THAT IS
THAT JUST THE END OF THE END OF
THE GAME AND I'M WORRIED ABOUT
THERE'S TALK ABOUT USING THE
FIGURES AS AS LOCATIONS WHEN WE
HAVE EMERGENCIES WHETHER THEIR
FIRE THEIR FLOOD AND ANYTHING
SO WE'RE GETTING RID OF ALL THE
LOOKS LIKE THE GAME PLAN IS TO
GET RID OF EVERYBODY. WE'VE GOT
WE'RE HAVING A DISCUSSION ON
WHETHER WE SHOULD HAVE
STATEWIDE BEDDING AND THE ADMIN.
OF THE AUTHORS SPECIFIC WE ARE
NOT ALLOWING FEARS TO TAKE BETS
ON SPORTS GAMES WHICH MIGHT
HELP THEM MEET MEET SOME OF THE
YEARLONG EXPENSES THAT THEY
HAVE SO I GUESS MY QUESTION IS.
WHAT HAPPENS AND THE ONE WITH
THE FAIRS BY. AND WHAT IS THE
PLAN THAT FINANCE AS FOR THE
ASSISTANCE FOR THIS THIS A
PARTNER THAT WE HAVE. THE
SERVICE WHEN OFFICE. YES SO ON
THIS ISSUE AND YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT- SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE YOU THAT THIS IS NOT A
POLICY PROVISION IN THIS BILL
THIS IS SIMPLY THE COST THAT WE
BELIEVE THAT WE ARE OBLIGATED
TO UNDERTAKE. AS THE STAIRS
THAT ARE STRUGGLING I TAKE PART
IN THE WHITE HOUSE PROCESS
WHICH WE KNOW IS VERY PAINFUL
AND THAT WHICH ARE YOU DESCRIBE
WELL I THINK RIGHT NOW THE PLAN
THERE ARE DISCUSSIONS ON THIS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO. DO YEAR- AND SO WE
WANT TO WORK YOU IN TERMS
DEVELOPING AN APPROACH FORKS
TRANSITION FOR MANY OF THESE
DIFFERENT SITES- AND IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT SUPPORTING. SOME
PROPERTIES MAY BE NECESSARY FOR
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS- SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE THINKING
ABOUT A LOT IT'S OBVIOUSLY IN
THE CONTEXT OF A VERY DIFFICULT
THAT BUDGET SITUATION WHERE
POINTING RESOURCES ANYWHERE HAS
TO BE WITH THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
SCRUTINY BUT BUT THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'RE CERTAINLY AWARE
OF- BUT STILL BACK TO THE
ORIGINAL POINT. IT'S NOT IT'S
STILL THERE STILL IS SIMPLY
WITH THE LAYOFFS THAT ARE.
EXPECTED TO COME IN THE NEXT
COUPLE WEEKS AND MONTHS MAKING
SURE THAT THE COST TO PAY FOR
THOSE EXPENSES RELATED TO-
ADDITIONAL. UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE RELATED EXPENSES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE LAYOFFS ARE
I'M- A TIME THAT NEEDS TO BE
PAID- THAT THE MONEY IS IN THE
BUDGET FOR THE- IN ADDITIONAL.
THAT ARE MORE LAW. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- THE SECOND ITEM.
IS FOR NINE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE GENERAL FUND TO
AUGMENT THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION FOR THEIR NEW
FACILITY IN STOCKTON US IS A
MEMBER OF SEVEN FIVE I DON'T
RECALL DISCUSSING THIS
PARTICULAR. EVENT I'M SURE WE
DID BUT- SINCE IT WAS THE
FACILITY WHICH WAS RECENTLY
CONSTRUCTED IS THIS IS THIS A
CONSTRUCTION DEFECT IN. IS THE
STATE DOING ANYTHING- IN
REGARDS TO. CONTACTING HER AT
ADDRESSING THIS MATTER WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION FIRM GENERAL
CONTRACTOR ANY OF THE- PARTIES
INVOLVED. MR THIS ONE OFTEN. I
WANT TO CLARIFY SENATOR MORE
LIKE IS THIS FOR CAN YOU
CLARIFY YOU SAID NINE POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS STUFF
WHICH WHICH ACILITY WHICH I
WANNA MAKE SURE I GOT THE RIGHT
AND REFORM I'M LOOKING AT ITEM
NUMBER TWO OF YOUR SIX
COMPONENTS FOR THE OVERALL
APPROPRIATION OF A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN MILLION- IT STATES
THAT. THE FACILITY AND STOCKTON
HAD LEGIONELLA BACTERIA WATER
SYSTEM HAD TO BE FIXED AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A BRAND NEW
FACILITY THAT WAS JUST RECENTLY
CONSTRUCTED SO I'M- CURIOUS IF
THIS WAS A DEFECT THAT. TO BE
ADDRESSED MAYBE. A IN A- EITHER
LEGAL MANNER OR OR AT LEAST
HAVE SOMEONE STEP UP- THAT THAT
THAT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS
OCCURRING AT THIS FACILITY. YES
THIS IS FOR REMEMBER MEDIATION
AT THAT WE CAN NOW- AT THAT
FACILITY AND BASICALLY- OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT HAPPENED
IS THAT THE WATER USE OF THE
FACILITIES WAS ACTUALLY LAST
THAN WHAT WAS INCLUDED IN THAT
DESIGN PLANS AND SO WHEN THERE
WAS A SLOWER FLOW OF WATER.
THAT CONTRIBUTED TO THE GREATER
POSSIBILITY OF THE GROWTH OF
BACTERIA AND THAT WAS ONE OF
THE CONTRIBUTING FACTORS SO I
KNOW THAT CITY SEE OURS TAKING
OUR CLOSER LOOK AT THIS AND
THAT THIS FUNDING IS FOR
IMMEDIATE REMEDIATION- BUT IT'S
ACTUALLY NOT NOT TO SOLVE THE
OVERALL ISSUE. AND SO THE WE DO
ALSO HAVE- BE KEY IN OUR BUDGET
PROPOSALS- WHEN IT COMES TO
BROADER REMEDIATION EFFORTS
THAT ARE NEEDED TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE BUT WHEN IT COMES TO SOME
OF THE SPECIFIC OF WHAT HAS
HAPPENED AND- YOU KNOW WHATEVER
DRIVERS TO MAKE SURE IT
DOESN'T. GET YOU WANT. GREAT
MAYBE THIS FROM. CA REMIND OF.
WHETHER OR NOT THIS WAS
DISCUSSED OR MAYBE COULD BE ON
THE AGENDA IN FUTURE MEETINGS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- AT. ONCE OR FOLLOW UP ON
SOME COMMENTS ABOUT THE FARE
MUCH THANK- SEVERAL CASKEY FOR
BRING THIS UP- NO CAL EXPO IS
CURRENTLY A SITE FOR BOTH-
SHELTERING SOME OF THE
HOMELESS- HERE IN SACRAMENTO
REGION WE'RE DOING TESTING
HERE- CLEARLY TO REVENUES FROM-
YOU KNOW WITH CANCEL THE
STATE'S SHARE THE COUNTY FAIR-
AND- BY THE WAY IT'S ALSO STATE
AGENCIES SO IT'S EXPENSES ARE
ACTUALLY HIGHER BECAUSE OF
STATE REQUIREMENTS. I WOULD
POINT THAT OUT. SO THE PERSON
OUT SPENCE'S ARE HIGHER BECAUSE
OF CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS STATE
IMPOSED ON CAL EXPO BECAUSE IT
IS A STATE AGENCY. SO I THINK
IT BEHOOVES THE STATE TO- AT
LEAST- AND LOOKING AT CAL EXPO
WHILE EXPECTING CAL EXPO. IN
THE PAST TO SUSTAIN ITSELF OFF
REVENUES FROM ACTIVITIES THAT
WE CANNOT DO ANYMORE- TO AT
LEAST HELP OUT WITH THE
INCREASED EXPENSES RELATED TO.
THE BEING A STATE AGENCY AND IN
ADDITION TO THAT RECOGNIZE
THAT. THE STATE USES THIS AS A
STAGING AREA FOR ALSO EMERGENCY
RESPONSE SO- BY LAYING OFF ALL
THE WORKERS THERE. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE CALYX
BUT WILL NOT BE THERE FOR THE
STATE WHEN THE STATE EXPECTS
SAID. SO WE GOT THE SIZE THE
SOMETHING THAT STATE ONCE IT'S
A STATE AGENCY. OR OR NOT AND-
I HOPE THAT- RECOGNIZING ALL
THE ACTIVITIES THAT TAKE PLACE
THERE THAT SUPPORT THE STATE.
AND THE FACT THAT STATE AGENCY
MEANS THAT DESERVES OUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ANY COMMENT FROM
FINANCE ELIO. UNDER STATE YES
WE WILL- WE WILL TAKE THAT
FEEDBACK THANK YOU. CENTER
MELENDEZ. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I JUST WANT TO GO BACK TO THE
COMMENTS- OF MY COLLEAGUE MARIN
COUNTY RELATING TO THE STOCKTON
FACILITY. IF I HIRE SOMEONE TO
COME IN A REPLACE THE PLUMBING
IN MY HOME. AND THE CONTRACTOR
COMES IN AND PERFORMS THE WORK
IN IT DOESN'T PERFORM THE WAY
IT'S SUPPOSED TO I DON'T THEN.
ASK THE CITY TO PICK UP THE TAB
FOR MAKING THE NECESSARY- FIXES
SO I DIDN'T HEAR ANYTHING IN
THE COMMENTS FROM THE ALLEY
SUGGESTING THAT. THE CONTRACTOR
WAS GOING TO BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE ON WHETHEROR NOT
THE WATER FLOW WAS WHAT THEY
THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO BE THAT
IS ALL PART OF THE DESIGN AND
PLANNING PROCESS WHEN YOU DO A
LARGE PROJECT LIKE THIS. SO FOR
ME IT GOES BACK TO THE
CONTRACTOR AND I JUST I NEED
SOME MORE CLARIFICATION FROM-
THE LA IS OFFICE. AS TO WHETHER
OR NOT THEY'RE GOING TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE BECAUSE THE
TAXPAYERS SHOULD NOT BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE FOR CONTRACTORS FOR
WHICH IS YOU KNOW HOW I'M DOING
THIS. SO YOU. I'M LOOKING FOR A
RESPONSE FROM BOTH ACTUALLY
OKAY. SO MISTER THIS ONE OFTEN.
YES THAT THAT FUNDING IS FOR
THE IMMEDIATE BASICALLY
EMERGENCY REMEDIATION EFFORTS
THAT HAVE TO TAKE PLACE ONCE
THIS PROBLEM WAS DISCOVERED TO
PREVENT ANY FURTHER ATTACKS OR
INJURIES THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
THOSE UNDERLYING ISSUES I. DO
WANT TO CHECK WITH OUR TEAM AND
MAKE SURE THAT I HAVE THE RIGHT
DETAILSFOR YOU IN TERMS OF HOW
THIS HAPPENED. NO I AND I HEARD
THE RESPONSE- THAT YOU MADE
EARLIER BY. IS THERE GOING TO
BE AN EFFORT TO THEN TRY TO
RECOUP THOSE FUNDS FROM THE
CONTRACTOR. BECAUSE IT SOUNDS
LIKE THIS IS A CONTRACTOR ERROR
TO ME SO I UNDERSTAND THEY WANT
TO FIX THE PROBLEM RIGHT NOW
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO PEOPLE'S
HEALTH BUT WILL WILL WE GET
THAT MONEY BACK FROM. FOR THE
TAXPAYERS. I WILL FALL DIRECTLY
WITH YOUR OFFICE ON THAT I NEED
TO CHECK WITH OUR TEAM OKAY
THANK YOU. COMING FROM LA L.
SORT OF BORED LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- CASES LIKE
THIS THE STATE IS ABSOLUTELY
FREE TO ATTEMPT TO- SEEK
COMPENSATION FROM THE PARTIES
THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE IN THIS
CASE- IT'S SOMEWHAT UNCLEAR AT
THIS POINT WHO WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT PART OF
THE ISSUE. IS THAT THE DESIGN
OF THE FACILITY WAS SUCH THEM
SO LARGE AND THE PIPES PIPING
WAS SO LONG. THAT WATER ENDED
UP STAYING IN CERTAIN PLACES
FOR EXTENDED PERIODS OF TIME
LEADING TO THE PROLIFERATION OF
THE BACTERIA SO THAT WE NEED TO
BE CRITICAL FOR THE STATE ND
THE DEPARTMENT TO TAKE A LOOK
AT WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
DESIGN AND TO ASSESS WHETHER OR
NOT IT HAS- YOU KNOW THE LEGAL
OPTION OF PURSUING COMPENSATION
BUT IT'S DEFINITELY SOMETHING
THAT. IS WORTH LOOKING INTO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. ON THE FIRST TRAILER
BILL AB SEVENTY FIVE. SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL MIKE SO LET'S MOVE
ON TO- AB SEVENTY SIX. WITH
SERVICE WHEN OFTEN VIA AND
AGAIN THIS IS EDUCATION FINANCE
AB SEVENTY SIX. YES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR ON EIGHTY SEVENTY
SIX- THIS IS EDUCATION FINANCE
RELATED TO AT PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT AND FUNDING FOR K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AT THE ACTUAL PACKAGE
FOR THE COMING YEAR THE BUDGET
YEAR- CONTINUES TO BE
NEGOTIATED BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR
AND MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE.
I JUST WANNA KNOW TWO ITEMS OF
NOTE THAT ARE IN THIS STILL FOR
YOU- THIS FIRST IS THERE CHIU
DEFERRALS I'VE CAGE FALL
FUNDING AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FUNDING FROM THE CURRENT YEAR
TO THE BUDGET YEAR AND THAT'S
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR K. TWELVE FUNDING AS WELL
AS THREE HUNDRED THIRTY NINE
DOLLARS IN KEEPING COLLEGE
FUNDING. AND SO THESE
EXPENDITURES THAT WERE
ORIGINALLY AT NINETEEN- BUDGET
ACTS WILL BE DEFERRED INTO NEXT
YEAR AND THEN THE SECOND ITEM
OF NOTE IS AN APPROPRIATION OF
A LITTLE OVER FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND THIS IS FOR
SATELLITE MAINTENANCE PAYMENTS-
TO SCHOOLS BASED ON PROPOSITION
EIGHTY EIGHT. FROM THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS AND- I HAVE ALSO
ON THE LINE WITH ME JESSICA
HOLMES SANDERS FORGET STANDS IS
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
THAT WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM
WHEN IT COMES TO THE SPECIFIC.
EXPENDITURES THANK YOU
QUESTIONS MEMBERS ON TRAILER
BILL. CENTER MORE LAW. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M JUST
CURIOUS- IF I COULD GET A
LITTLE MORE DETAIL WHITE WIRE
WE DIFFER IN. A PAYMENT WE'RE
WE'RE SHIFTING AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. THAT I CAN
EXPLAIN THIS CLEARLY. A SERVICE
FOR NOTHING. YES THESE ARE-
DEFERRALS ARE OFTEN HAVE
HAPPENED BEFORE BY THE STATE
AND WHEN WE ARE IN
CIRCUMSTANCES SIMILAR TO WHAT
WE ARE TODAY WHAT COMES TO THE
SPECIFICS OF HOW THE SMALL
OPERATE I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE JUST A HOMES. FOR THE-
ARE YOU TO FIND DEFERRAL THIS
ALONE. HIS HOME. THANK YOU IS
MORE LAX SO THE WAY THAT THE
DEFERRAL WORKS IS GENERALLY
SPEAKING. PRIVATE SCHOOLS AND
COLLEGES IN THE MONTH OF JUNE
SO THIS THIS MONTH TO CLAMOR TO
KILLER TOWARDS THE END OF THE
MONTH AND WHAT E ARE PROPOSING
IN ORDER TO ALLOW. THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEED TO BE FUN MINIMUM
LEVEL AND ITS RECORD CLOSING.
HAVE THAT PAYMENT GO OUT AT THE
BEGINNING OF JUNE TO JULY
DEFERRAL AND IN THIS CASE IT'S
VERY SIMILAR TO THAT. MISS
HOMES YOU FOR A POST JUST FOR A
MOMENT TO JUST RESTATE THAT
LAST SECTION OF YOUR ANSWER
PLEASE. COLLEGE EYES. TO WHAT
WOULD OTHERWISE YOU KNOW
COLLEGE JUNE TO JULY DEFERRAL
SO WE'RE JUST PROVIDING TE
SAME PAYMENT THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE PROVIDED
BUT IN JULY AND- SO IF I WERE
TO GO BACK TO PRIOR YEARS I SEE
SIMILAR. MOVEMENTS SO THIS IS
NOT SOMETHING NEW OR UNIQUE
JUST BECAUSE OF MISTER RESPONSE
ON SAID THIS WE DO THIS IN.
THESE KINDS OF ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS I'D LIKE TO BE A
SURE THAT WE DO THIS EVERY YEAR.
WE DON'T DO THIS EVERY YEAR BUT
WE HAD WE DID DO THE SEVERAL
TIMES DURING THE LAST RECESSION.
SO IT'S OKAY ALI BUT THERE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ON THIS
TRAILER BILL. SEEING NONE LET'S
GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY FIVE
REGARDING REVENUES MR THIS ONE
OFTEN. ON ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY
FIVE THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT REVENUE ITEMS IN THIS
TALE I'LL JUST TOUCH ON SOME OF
THE HIGHLIGHTS OF THE FIRST
REALLY OPERATING LOSSES AND I
KNOW THAT WE HAD A DISCUSSION
EARLIER IN THE HEARING ON WHAT
SENATOR MORE LOCK IN SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS RAISED. BUT
BASICALLY AT AS THE COST THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD SUSPENDED THE
USE OF NET OPERATING LOSSES FOR
TAXPAYERS WITHIN THE BOTTOM ONE
MILLION DOLLARS. THREE YEARS
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY YEAR
THREE TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO YEAR
ON AND ANYBODY- WHO IS. THE
ABILITY TO USE THAT OPERATING
LOSS FOR THOSE THREE YEARS WELL
RECEIVED A CARRY OVER A PERIOD
AS WELL TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
CAN USE THEM. THE SECOND. NEW
ITEM OF NOTE THAT THAT WAS IN
OUR MY REVISION- BUT NOW WITH
SOME ADJUSTMENTS. IS A TOP ON
BUSINESS INCENTIVE CREDITS
THESE WOULD BE CAPPED PERSON
WERE BEARD OF TIME FOR THREE
YEARS. I KNOW. TWO EIGHT
BUSINESS. OF CRAP BACK BE USED
WAS DID. SOLELY BECAUSE OF THIS
LOCATION FORTY THREE YEARS
THERE WOULD BE A CARRYOVER
PERIOD AS WELL AND SO THOSE TWO
PROVISIONS TOGETHER ARE
ESTIMATED TO RAISE. A LITTLE
BIT OVER FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
NEXT YEAR AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL- FINDS. IT USED AS
CREDITS BECAUSE OF THOSE
PROVISIONS. WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO USE THEM IN
FUTURE YEARS SO THIS IS SIMPLY
A STAT. EVERYBODY'S DOING THEIR
PART THAT MEASURE SIMILAR TO
THIS HAVE BEEN UNDER. IN PAST
RECESSION. AND MAKE SURE THE
STATE GENERATE SOME ADDITIONAL
REVENUE IN A WAY THAT MAKES
SENSE AND THAT IS THERE. ANY TO
THAT THERE ARE A COUPLE OF THE
OTHER ITEMS OF NOTE THAT I WANT
TO MENTION- THE FIRST IS THE
EXTENSION FOR THE CRIER. FILM
TAX CREDIT OF THAT PERIOD SIX
NINE YEARS. THE SECOND IS A
PART. THAT WE ALL INSURE AN ARM
REPLACE TO MAKE SURE THAT CAR
DEALERS ARE REMAINING SALES. TO
THE STATE AND THEN IN ADDITION
TO THAT WE ALSO HAVE PROPOSED.
TO BE EXAM. ON SALES FOR.
DIAPERS AND MEN'S HYGIENE
PRODUCTS FOR. AT UNTIL TWENTY
TWO THREE. I'M AS WELL AS A PER.
THAT THE ADMIN. HAD ENGINE. TO
PROVIDE AN EXAM. FOR THE
LLC THAT WE HOPE WILL AN- UP
OVER SOME OF BARRIERS TO START
BUSINESS JUST. EACH GIVE ME.
TIME THAT WERE RIGHT NOW. SO
THOSE SOME OF THE- ARE BETTER
HE- FELT HAPPY TO ANY QUESTIONS
IT AND WE ALSO HAVE JAKE. WHEN
FROM THE DEPARTMENT ON FINANCE
WHO'S ALSO YOUR HELP ME AND-
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR DOLLINGER. THIRTY DOLLY.
YOUR BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN DOING THEIR PART THAT'S
THE REASON THAT WE HAVE. A
RESERVE THAT WERE RELYING ON
RIGHT NOW AND YOU TALK ABOUT
REVENUES REVENUES ARE TAXES TO
BUSINESSES. AND I HAPPEN TO BE
ONE OF THOSE BUSINESS OWNERS
DIE DON'T MAKE A MILLION SO I
KNOW I'M GONNA BE UNDERNEATH
THAT. BUT THERE ARE SEVERAL
THOUSANDS OF BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA THEY DO MAKE OVER
MILLION DOLLARS AND THEY'VE
BEEN DOING THEIR PART FOR THE
LAST. TEN YEARS AND WE'VE HAD
THIS ECONOMIC GROWTH THAT WE'VE
BEEN PENALIZED AND SO. WHAT'S
THE REASON THAT IF YOU WERE A
BUSINESS OR YOU WOULD STAY IN
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO SOMEWHERE
ELSE. AND PRODUCE YOUR PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES. SO I'M I'M KIND
OF BATTLE THAT IT DID COME IN
OF. SAY THAT BUSINESSES NEED TO
DO THEIR PART WHEN WE KNOW THAT
THEY HAVE DONE THEIR PART AND
WE GET WE GOT PROP THIRTY WHICH
GOT EXTENDED WHICH WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE- SHORT TERM AS WELL. AND
SO I I'M COULD I THINK THAT'S
KIND OF I KNOW THAT WERE
SUPPOSEDLY. IN A YOU KNOW.
RECESSION HERE BUT IT'S A
RECESSION THAT'S BEEN CAUSED-
BY KOBE. AND WE KNOW THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GET SOME OF THAT
REFUNDED- WHICH I ASKED LAST
TIME ABOUT HOW MUCH DO WE
EXPECT TO GET FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- EMERGENCY FUNDING
THAT COMES BACK SO- I JUST I
GUESS MY QUESTION WOULD BE. AS
A BUSINESS OWNER WHAT DOES THE
FUTURE LOOK LIKE FOR ME.
SERVICE NUMBER. YES I'LL SPEAK
I SPECIFICALLY TO THESE
PROVISIONS AND SPEAK- I GET A
LITTLE BIT MORE BROADLY I THINK
A SPECIFIC TO THESE PROVISIONS
THAT WE DID- THE ADMINISTRATION
DID A DESIGNED AND IN A WAY TO
MINIMIZE THE IMPACT BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT THAT CAN DOWN MAKE IS
HAVING AN IMPACT ON ALL
CALIFORNIA OR SIGN ALL
CALIFORNIANS ON WORKERS AS WELL
AS ON BUSINESSES AND RISKING
THOSE IMPACTS ALL ROUND AT THE
STATE AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS ENGAGED
IN THAT TASK FORCE ON THAT JOBS
AND BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
RECOVERY I WOULD STAKEHOLDERS
FROM SMALL BUSINESSES LARGER
BUSINESS THERE IS. WAIT I
STAKEHOLDERS WITHIN THE
LEGISLATURE EVERYONE IS WORKING
ON AND WHEN IT COMES TO THESE
SPECIFIC PROVISIONS NUMBER ONE
WE DID WANT TO BUILD AND-
MAKING SURE THAT IF YOU HAVE
BEEN A DISINCENTIVE CREDITS-
BUT THEY ARE UNDERSTOOD MILLION
DOLLARS YOU ARE TO USE THAT IF
YOU HAVE AN OPERATING LOSSES
AND YOUR INCOME IS LESS THAN
ONE MILLION DOLLARS ARE YOU NOT
OPERATING LOSS WHICH BUT- ALSO
IF YOU ARE IN THOSE WORRIES.
AND WHERE YOU ALL I ONE OF
THOSE EXAMS WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT IS
DESIRED BUT THAT'S WHAT RECENT
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT AS
THE ECONOMY FIRST ANY IS THAT I
THE EIGHTY THE OPERATING DAYS
OR BUSINESS INCENTIVES RATES
NOW WILL BE OP IN THE BAND TO
USE THEM IN THE FUTURE AND WE
KNOW THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY SO
THAT. LOVE IN TERMS OF THE
WHOLE PACKAGE WE DID TRY TO NO
WHERE ALL WHO ARE. WEST THIS IS
ASKED THEY WILL THANKS. ALL IS
THAT AND PUMP IT UP. WATER SURE
AND ONE REALLY KNOWS HOW THE
NEXT YEARS. OUR GOING TO GO A
CERTAIN IN. AND IF YOU ACCEPT
THIS BUDGET DID NOT HAVE A COPY
TERMS LOW THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED
AND KNOW THAT WE RECEIVED OF
HEAT AS AN ALL OF THE IN THE
WATCHES HAD. ABOUT THE EXTRA OF
THOSE. AND THE PAIN THAT MAY
CALL BUT THE- CERTAINLY UNDER
THAT WERE OPERATING A VERY DE
BY. AND WHY OF THE BEST THINGS
THAT WE CAN DO IS SURE THAT
EVEN AS WE ARE MAKING THESE
THAT'S WE ARE MADE SAYING THE
ARM THAT WE CAN YOU AND- MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE LANES. FOR A
ROBOT WORK. AND SO I THINK WHEN
WE LOOK IN THE CONTEXT OF OUR
OVERALL PACKAGE GIVEN HOW MUCH
TRAFFIC USE ARE FALLING OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS. WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS WAS OPERATE
MEASURE FOR THOSE THREE YEARS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO MAKE SOME
INVESTMENTS ARE WAYS NOT CUT
THEM BACK AS MUCH AS WE WOULD
THEIR RIGHTS HAVE TO CUT THEM
BACK AND THEN AS THE ECONOMY
COVERS. THOSE BUSINESSES ARE
OTHER TAX PAPERS THAT HAVE
THESE NET OPERATING LOSSES
HOBBIES BUSINESS INSTEAD OF
CREDITS AND EVEN WITH THE
GUARDRAILS THAT WE PUT IN PLACE
ARE NOT ABLE TO USE THEM RIGHT
NOW THEY WILL BE ABLE TO USE
THOSE AND- THE DALAI FOLLOW. IT
MAY JUST MAKE A CALL THAT AND
LAST COUPLE MONTHS WE'VE SEEN
BUSINESSES WHO. DO NOT KNOW
WHAT THE FUTURE'S GO HOLES IN
THEIR THE BUSINESSES THAT
CREATE JOBS WE'VE SEEN WE KNOW
WHAT IS HAPPENED IN THE JOB
MARKET BECAUSE WE SEE THE
UNEMPLOYMENT SKYROCKETING
PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY LOST THEIR
JOBS. SO TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
AN ECONOMY THAT'S GOING TO WORK
BUSINESSES HAVE TO HIRE PEOPLE
AND THEN PEOPLE CAN HAVE A JOB
AND THEY CAN PAY. TAXES BOTH
THE BUSINESS AND THE INDIVIDUAL
SO I CAUTION YOU TO THINK THAT
IF WE HAD A LOT OF THESE
BUSINESSES ARE ON THE COST OF
IT OR ARE THEY GOING TO STAY IN
BUSINESS OR NOT. SO IF YOU.
DON'T ALLOW THEM TO DIFFER.
EVEN IF THEY'RE OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS- THEY MAY NOT BE IN
BUSINESS AND THEN THERE IS FOR
SURE A RECESSION BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO HIRE
PEOPLE SO I JUST. WANT TO MAKE
THAT POINT AND DRIVING HOME
THE- BUSINESSES HIRE PEOPLE.
YOU CANNOT HAVE A JOB UNTIL
SOMEBODY HIGHER YOU. AND YOU
CAN'T PAY TAXES TELL SOMEBODY
PAYS YOU FIRST. SO IT'S- IT'S
NOT PRODUCTIVE TO PENALIZE A
BUSINESS HE WAS ALREADY BEEN
PENALIZED UNFORTUNATELY BY KOBE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIR ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OF
MEMBERS. THIRTY MORE LIVE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THE STAFF
REPORT FOR THIS BILL SPENDS A
LOT OF TIME TALKING ABOUT USED
CAR DEALERS AND GETTING THEIR
SALES TAX- INTO THE- CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS AND- IT JUST SEEMS. RICH
TO ME- THREE MONTHS AGO WE WERE
BRAGGING ABOUT BEING TWENTY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS- IN IN BUDGET
SURPLUS AND NOW WE'RE DOING
THAT FLOW GAME WERE ASKING.
WHEN INDUSTRY TO PAY THE SALES
TAX A WHOLE LOT SOONER AND IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE WHAT HOW
QUICKLY THE MONEY OF FALLEN
BUT- WHY DON'T WE JUST REQUIRE
THAT USED CAR. DEALERSHIPS FILE
THEIR SALES TAX RETURNS EVERY
MONTH. INSTEAD OF QUARTERLY OR
SEMI ANNUALLY OR ANNUALLY- WE
SPENT A WHOLE LOT OF SPACE. ON
THIS AND I'M I'M JUST CURIOUS.
IF THE IF THERE'S NOTHING TO BE
GAINED INTEREST RATES ARE JUST
ABOUT ZERO SO I'M JUST. I'M
JUST SORT OF CURIOUS WHY. AND I
THINK WE'RE JUST TALKING I MEAN
TRYING TO. HAVE A TIME VALUE
MONEY JUST THE MINIMUM SO I'M
I'M JUST ONE MORE WE SPEND SO
MUCH TIME PLAYING THE FULL GAME
WITH THIS INDUSTRY. THE SERVICE
WILL OFTEN YOU CARE TO RESPOND
YES- SENATOR MORE A LOT ON THIS
ISSUE I'LL SPEAK BRIEFLY AND
THEN I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE TO CHAMBERLAIN WHO
MAY HAVE ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
THE WAY THAT WE ARE THINKING
ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL THIS IS
NOT. REALLY A TIME VALUE MONEY
PROPOSAL OR AS NECESSARILY AN
ACCELERATION PROPOSAL ALSO MATS
SENSE IT'S DIFFERENT FROM THAT
OF THE THAT WE WERE I WAS AND
DOLLY HAD ASKED ABOUT WHERE IT
IS ABOUT WHEN CERTAIN PAYMENTS
ARE PAID OR WHEN THEY CAN BE
USED THIS CASE IS DIFFERENT
THIS IS ABOUT USED CAR DEALERS
THAT ARE AT. MAYBE NOT
REMAINING SALES TAX AND ALL OR
CERTAINLY NOT IN THE AMOUNT
THAT THEY ARE LEGALLY OBLIGATED
TO REMAIN BASED ON THE ACTUAL
VALUE OF THE SALE SO THIS IS
REALLY AN ENFORCEMENT ISSUE
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYONE IS ON
A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD MORE THAN
A TIME VALUE OF MONEY ISSUE BUT
LET ME TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE TO CHAMBERLAIN'S WHO
CAN TALK ABOUT ADDITIONAL.
SKILLED THANK YOU. SO I AS HIS
VINCE. SAID ON THIS REALLY IS
NOT ABOUT. OR REVENUE. IT'S
ABOUT TRYING TO CLOSE THE TACK
GAP. THAT EXISTS RIGHT NOW. NOT
FOR THE MID OF USE CAR DEALERS
NECESSARILY BUT FOR A CERTAIN
SEGMENT OF USED CAR DEALERS WHO
ARE NOT- REMITTING THE SALES
TAX AND THE CLOCK ON CARS- AND
SO THIS IS JUST A MECHANISM. TO
MAKE THAT. TO MAKE THE LEAKAGE
MORE CLOSELY SO THAT SO THAT
THEY WOULD BE REQUIRED TO REMIT
YEAH. NOT BE ABLE TO GET AWAY
WITH NOT. READING THE CELLS.
THAT WE'RE GOING AFTER BAD
PLAYERS. NUMBER BY THE WERE
ALSO SPENDING TWENTY. MILLION
THE LAUGHTER GOOD PLAYERS WITH
GOING AFTER INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS THAT HAVE BEEN. SO
I'M JUST TRYING TO. FIGURE OUT
HOW WE'RE ALLOCATING FUNDS AND
WHAT WHAT THE PRIORITIES ARE
HERE WE SAW AND MAYBE I'M JUST.
JUST THE EXASPERATED I WILL
STOP THERE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS. OKAY SEEN
NINE. I'D LIKE TO- THANK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE LA
OILS OFFICE FOR PARTICIPATING
TODAY AND I'D LIKE TO INVITE
THE PUBLIC WANTED TO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC COMMENT
TO CALL IN NOW PLEASE DIAL THIS
TOLL FREE NUMBER. ONE EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR WHEN PROMPTED
PLEASE USE THIS ACCESS CODE.
SIX TWO FIVE ZERO SEVEN THREE
ZERO AND AGAIN THOSE NUMBERS
ARE ON OUR SCREEN. DID TO
CONSTRAIN FOR VERY THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN NEW CLEARLY
PROTOCOLS ARE INSTITUTING TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY
EACH PERSON PROVIDING COMMENT
WILL BE PERMITTED A TOTAL OF
ONE MINUTE I MAY HAVE TO
SHORTEN THIS TIME LIMIT BASED
ON THE NUMBER OF CALL IS THAT
WE HAVE. A LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY.
ONE MINUTE PLEASE THANK YOU.
YES MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CHRIS MY KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF
COUNTY THE COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION THIS IS IN
REFERENCE TO- AB EIGHTY FIVE
THE REVENUE TRAILER BILL AND WE
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE. THE I KNOW
WELL SUSPENSION AND THE TAX
CREDIT LIMITATION. BUT WE THINK
IT'S THE WRONG TIME FOR THESE-
PROVISIONS TO BE ENACTED.
FUNDAMENTALLY THE FOUR POINT
FOUR BILLION TO BE RAISED IN
THE IN THE- BUDGET YEAR MEANS
INCREASED TAX LIABILITY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND PRIMARILY
BUSINESSES THAT MEANS LESS
MONEY FOR. INVESTMENT FOR OUR
IN DE FOR PAYING WAGES AND TO
MAKE MATTERS WORSE THE PROPOSAL
IS FOR THREE YEARS. NOW I NOTED
WITH INTEREST OF THE DEPARTMENT
AND INDICATED THAT THIS HAS
BEEN DONE PREVIOUSLY WITH OTHER
BUDGET DEFICITS. THAT IS
PARTIALLY TRUE THE ISSUE IS
WHAT WE DID SUSPEND AND A WELL
TO PRIOR TIMES IN BOTH
INSTANCES IT WAS ONLY FOR A TWO
YEAR PERIOD NOT THREE AND THERE
WERE SWEETENERS IF YOU WILL ON
THE BACKEND WHICH ALLOWED
GREATER. CONFORMITY WITH
FEDERAL LAW ON THE TAX CREDIT
PROVISION IT WAS DONE ONCE
BEFORE AND WE DID A 50% LIMIT
RATHER THAN A FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR CAP. COM TIA AND TECHNET
AND OTHER GROUPS HAVE INDICATED
PLEASE IF YOU'RE GOING TO DO
THIS.DO IT WITH AMENDMENTS HOW
ABOUT ONE YEAR WHICH STILL
INSURERS A GREAT DEAL OF
REVENUE. BUT MAKE OTHER AND
THEN YOU CAN COME BACK AND
REVISIT IT NEXT SPRING AND THEN
ALLOW ON THE TAX CREDIT SIDE A
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR CAP OR A
50% CREDIT USAGE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT SERGEANTS
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN.
HEARING ROOM TWENTY FORTY
BECAUSE I DON'T SEE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE GALLEY GALLERY. ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEEN NONE.
WILL MOVE NOW INTO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORIFICES
WELL GOOD MORNING MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE GIVE ME THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF
YOU OPEN THE LINE TO ANNOUNCE
EACH COLOR INDIVIDUALLY WILL
BEGIN HEARING FROM THE PUBLIC.
I'D BE GLAD TO AND ALSO- LEAVES
ON IF YOU'D LIKE TO QUEUE UP
FOR WITNESS HER TESTIMONY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO WILL OPEN
UP YOUR LINE. FIRST RECALL TWO
LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN LINE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LYNN
KERR SEE AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF MATERNAL AND CHILD HEALTH
ACCESS INTO HUMAN SERVICES AND
POLICY ORGANIZATION LOS ANGELES
WORKING ON LOCAL AND STATEWIDE
HEALTH ISSUES. I APPLAUD YOUR
LEADERSHIP SENATOR MITCHELL AND
THAT OF THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE
OVERALL IN PRESENTING A BUDGET
THAT'S BALANCED AND MINIMIZES
HARMFUL CUTS. ESPECIALLY TO
BLACK INFANT MATERNAL HEALTH.
DENTAL AND OTHER CARE MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH AND HEALTH
NAVIGATORS WHO- OUR REGION IS
JUST BE ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO
ARE WORKING IN LOW PAYING JOBS
WITHOUT HEALTH INSURANCE. AND
IN ADDITION IS THE REVENUE SURE
CONSIDERING I WANT TO ENCOURAGE
A LOOK AT THE INDUSTRY'S
PROFITING FROM THE CORPORATE
OUTBREAK WITTINGLY OR AND WOOD
WAITING LEE THESE BUSINESSES
ARE NOT SUFFERING. TECHNOLOGY
DELIVERY HE COMMERCE GROCERY
STORES WHICH IN MID MARCH HAD
ALREADY SEEN A 100% INCREASE IN
REVENUE. THE STATE IS
CONTRACTING WITH AMAZON AND
WALMART FOR CALPERS PURCHASES.
AND THESE BUSINESSES CAN AFFORD
TO- CONTRIBUTE MORE TO THE-
CULVERT OUTBREAK IN THIS HARM
THAT IT'S CAUSING MANY OF
WORKER PERHAPS BY THERE ARE.
ASKED THEIR OWN. IT MIGHT.
WHO'S MAKING ME AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
HUMAN NEEDS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SEE MODERATE MAC WITNESS
PLEASE. MY PLEASURE NEXT OPEN
MY THREE YEAR IS NOW. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS LIKE NOT SURE
HERNANDEZ AND SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA. WE
HAVE CONCERNS WITH A PROVISION
IN TRAILER BILL EIGHTY FIVE. US
OUR DEALERSHIPS WE DO SUPPORT
THE CONCEPT- INSURING THAT THE
DEALERSHIPS DO EXTRACT TRANSMIT
COLLECT SALES TAX ON THAT IS
NOT OUR CONCERN OUR CONCERN IS
THAT AS DRAFT DATE CONSUMERS
WILL NOT RECEIVE THE
REGISTRATION IS THAT ACTORS DO
NOT FOR THE SALES TAX. THAT IS
COULD LEAD TO SEVERAL PROBLEMS
IN PARTICULAR BECAUSE A
CONSUMER MAY HAVE NO IDEA THAT
THE DEALERS NOT FOR THE SALES
TAX ON THE MAY BE WAITING FOR
THE REGISTRATION IN THE MAIL IT
MAY NOT COME. THEY WERE NOT BE
AWARE THAT IT WOULD SELL STOCK
TRANSFER SO SOME TELL PERHAPS
WHEN THE PULLED OVER AND THE
REGISTRATION FROM. OR PERHAPS
ON THEIR OWN JUST EIGHTY.
WONDER WHY THEY HAVE TO REVIEW
THE REGISTRATION A LOT PUBLIC
DEALERSHIP. ALL THE EMPTY
OFFICE A WAY TO REMEDY. BETTER
MAYBE PUT IN PLACE WE SEEN AS
AND CAL. WE HAVE CHECKED IN TAX
THERE REPORTER PROBLEMS THE
LAST MONTHS THEY HAVE A SIMILAR
PROCESS AND THE CONSUMERS LEFT
HOLDING THE BAG WITHOUT
REGISTRATION OR RUNNING THE
RISK OF JOINING. REGISTRATION
NOT ANY NOTICE SO WE DO ASK
THAT SOMEHOW THAT IS CLEANED UP
GOING FORWARD WE DO SUPPORT
HOLDING ELECTIONS ACCOUNTABLE
JUST AFTER SIX PROTOCOLS FOR
THE CONSUMERS. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NFL BUT MY NUMBER
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DUSTIN WHAT IT BE WITH
A CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION RIGHT HERE SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE LARGER BROAD
COALITION FIFTY SIX TAXPAYERS
THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
NINE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR
TAX PROPOSALS. CONTAINED IN
EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE WHICH IS
SPENDING AND ALL THE DUCKS IN A
MOMENT TAX INCENTIVES. THE TAX
INCREASES WILL HARM
CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESSES
SIGNIFICANTLY SLOW DOWN THE
STATE ECONOMIC RECOVERY. ON THE
BUDGET ESTIMATES FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
IT'S NOT EVEN CLEAR EIGHTY
EIGHTY FIVE NECESSARY SO AT THE
VERY LEAST WE ENCOURAGE A
LEGISLATOR BE SURE WHETHER THIS
BILL ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY. AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU FOR TALKING.
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
AND NEXT ALTER MY NUMBER
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTY FIVE WHICH PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED REVENUE TO PREVENT
DEVASTATING. IMPACT FOR
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHO'VE
ALREADY BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC KAMALA
VISION HEALTH CUTS ARE AIMED AT
SENIORS AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR I REINSTATING BETWEEN
YOUR PENALTY CUTTING MEDI CAL
BENEFITS. LOW LEVEL OKAY
REGULATED HEALTH COVERAGE
EXCITING IN STATE RECOVERY THE
TARGET THE HOMES THE POOR BLACK
WHITE NEXT API FAMILY AND
CUTTING FUNDING FOR THE BACK IN
GOOD HEALTH PROGRAM AND HELP
NAVIGATOR. AB AT BY THE
JAPANESE EQUITY CONCERNS ARE
RATING SOME OF THE REVENUE
NEEDED TO PREVENT. HAD SOME
CLEAN UP WILL BE NEEDED TO GET
DEALERS TO FOR TAX DOLLARS TO
SEE AND BE WITHOUT ANY
TECHNICAL. OF CAR BUYERS THE
ABLE REGULATE THEIR VEHICLE
INCREASED THE COMMERCE. OUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND NEXT
MY NUMBER TWENTY YEAR LAW AND
NOW OF. HI THE IS DIRTY HER
NAME WITH THE CAL. STATE IF. A
COUNTY WHERE'S THE ONE BILL
DOLLARS FILL FOR BOTH NINETEEN
NINETY. AND TWO ELEVEN WE AND-
BOTH IN ONE AND LET RELY. SIGN
THE STATE ACT THAT PROVIDE THE
BUT SERVICES THE PEOPLE. AND
SERVICES ARE. UNDER THE CO
NINETY PANDEMIC WE REQUEST THE
DOLLAR BACK TO THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD MORNING BATTLE
COLEMAN WITH HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA HEARING SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE BUT WOULD
LIKE TO SEE COMING UP AT THE
RELATED TO THE SALE TAX
COLLECTION ISSUE RELATED TO USE
CARS WE APPRECIATE THE LITERACY
LEADERSHIP HERE MADAM CHAIR ON
REVENUE. IN LIGHT OF THE
DEFICIT WE ARE FACING REVENUE
IS NEEDED TO PREVENT CUT THE
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
COMMUNITIES NEED WE SUPPORT THE
STRUCTURE THE REVENUE PACKAGE
OUTLINED IN EIGHTY FIVE BUT WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE THE THOUGHT
ENOUGH. WE URGE LEGISLATORS TO
MAKE TOUGH DECISIONS TO BRING
MORE REVENUE INTO THE
CONVERSATION GIVEN THE DEPTH
WE'RE FACING- MOST CERTAINLY WE
ALL KNOW THAT THE BUDGET IS A
STATEMENT OF VALUES IN THE
STATE AND A LOT OF WORK TO DO
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT. OUR ANY.
BRING A COULD BE EQUITY TO CAL.
ALL CAL BUT PARTICULARLY THE
BLACK FAMILIES IMMIGRANT AND
OTHER P. OF COLOR WHETHER WE
CLOSE CORD LOOPHOLE THAT BEEN
ABUSED FOR DEBT WHETHER WE TO
CONSIDER TAX ARE REASONS ON
HIGH IN EARNERS WHAT LONG LIST
OF OTHER TO GROW SALUTE WE DO.
NEED MORE REVENUE IN ADDITION
TO EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE BUT
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP HERE- AND URGED THE
LEGISLATURE TO CAN YOU TO THINK
ABOUT HOW TO BRING MORE REVENUE
INTO THE DISCUSSION SO WE CAN
GET SOME MORE EQUITABLE BUDGET
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
DANIELLE ELIGE AND I AM IN THE
A WORKER I'M AN ENVIRONMENTAL
SCIENTIST AND I'M ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA. PROFESSIONAL
PLAINTIFFS AND I JUST WANTED TO
CALL AND  FELT COMPELLED TO
THINK THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
SENATE FOR CONSIDERING. OF NOT
PUSHING FORWARD FOUR EIGHT. CUT
IN WAGES AND HELL WE HAVE A
PENDING FEDERAL- BAILOUT MONEY
AND I ALSO JUST WANTED TO
MENTION THAT. WE ARE MOST OF
THE WORKERS ARE MIDDLE CLASS
WORKERS AND WE CONTRIBUTE TO
THE ECONOMY AND JUST PERSONALLY
I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE IMPORTANT
EXPRESSED HERE THAT IF WE DO A
LITTLE FOR LOW OR SOME SORT OF
PAY CUT BUT THAT IS GOING TO
DRASTICALLY IMPACT. MY CAN USE
A CONTRIBUTION TO THE ECONOMY
OF THE PULL BACK AND I WON'T BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT MY COMMUNITY OF
FINANCIALLY. AND I DIDN'T GET
THE GENTLEMAN'S NAME BUT I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE GENTLEMAN
THAT SPOKE- ABOUT THE WORKERS
AND THE SACRIFICES THAT WERE
ALL MAKING RIGHT NOW INCLUDING
YOU KNOW BEING REASSIGNED
TRACKING TRADE. AND HOW WE ARE
LEADING. BEHIND AND THEIR NOT.
AND THAT INDEED WE ARE ASKED IF
YOU'LL WORK NOW THAT WE EVER
HAVE AND THANK SO MUCH FOR TIME
I ALL OF THE WORKING KNOWLEDGE
TO HELP OUT THE STATE BUDGET
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND THAT
WAS. CAN THAT YOU WERE
REFERENCE THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
THE NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
GOOD MORNING THIS IS BILL IS
HERE WITH THAT BOYS ARE NOT
INSURE MEMBERS I'M CALLING-
REGARDING THE ISSUE OF
DEFERRALS AND WHILE I KNOW THAT
IN AB SEVENTY FIVE THERE'S NO
HARDSHIP EXEMPTION. IT MAY WORK
FOR THE CURRENT YEAR BUT IT IT
CERTAINLY WOULDN'T WORK FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR WITHOUT HARDSHIP
EXEMPTIONS VERTICALLY GIVEN
THAT THE LEGISLATIVE GREEN AND-
HAS A 100% INCREASE FROM WHERE
THE GOVERNOR WAS IN THE
PROPOSED REVISION- TYPICALLY WE
KNOW THAT THE POLICY OF
DEFERRALS. ARE DUBIOUS IN THE
GALLERY WITHOUT A FORMAL
SUSPENSION OF PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT UNLESS THERE'S AN
OVER CORPORATION- THE BECAUSE
REVENUES DID FALL OFF THE CLIP
WE UNDERSTAND THAT- THIS YEAH
THIS THE MEASURE- COULD BE VIEW
THAT APPROPRIATE NONETHELESS AT
A MINIMUM GOING FORWARD. FOR
THAT THE BUDGET YEAR DOUBLES WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE STATE YOU
GET PAID SHOULD ADDRESS THE
HARDSHIP ISSUE AND AS A
TECHNICAL MATTER. WHATEVER
DOLLAR AMOUNT WE RECOMMEND
CONTROL LANGUAGE TO GIVE
AUTHORITY TO DIRECT FINANCE TO
INCREASE THAT ALLOCATION AND
WITHOUT HAVING TO COME BACK THE
LEGISLATURE DID YOU KNOW THAT.
YOU CAN BE VERY. A LITTLE
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOL
YOU ARE COMMON CIGNA.
DIFFERENCE THE AND CAL ON BASIS.
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT MY
NUMBER TWENTY SIX YEAR MIND
ITSELF. HI GOOD THIS IS WHY
CALLING FROM THE CAL YOUTH AT.
THE PATIENT TO OUR IN RELATION
TO AB AT. AND ARE OFTEN TO THE
MAC OPERATE LAW BENCH AND THE
CAT CREDIT HALF WE ALSO.
RECOGNIZE THAT THE STATE AT
HALLOWEEN ACTION BEER- BUDGET
DEFICIT DUE TO THE CO THAT
NINETEEN AND THEN I BUT ARE
CONCERNED THAT THE PROPOSAL'S
WILL REDUCE RATHER NEED TO
REBUILD REPURPOSE IN REMOTE
MANUFACTURING FACILITY SO THAT
WE CAN COME BY. THEN AND PLAYED
OUR WILL CORD AFTER WORK
FURTHER WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE IMPACT THAT THESE PROPOSALS.
ON RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
WHICH IS CRITICAL. TO THE STATE
ABILITY TO CALL BACK BECAUSE IT
NINETEEN GOING FORWARD WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE ALL TURN
CAN. AND AMENDMENTS THAT COULD
BE TAKEN FOR THIS PROPOSAL
INCLUDING THE ELIMINATION OF
THE FIVE MILLION DOLLAR CAP FOR
THE TAX CREDIT UTILIZATION. IN
IN AT. HAND CAP. LIABILITY FOR
YOU TO LOOK. I WELL WE LOOK
LIKE THE CREDIT YOU. AND THE
THAT OPERATE LOSS PENSION. HI
FRAME DURATION TO BE RID FROM
THREE. TO TWO YEAR THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE TWO NINE YEAR
LINE IS NOW. THANK YOU MATT
CHAIR NUMBER FUNDED WITH THE
CAL TIME AND CAL NETWORK I
WOULD LIKE TO AVOID OUR SUPPORT
FOR AT FIVE. AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- THE BILL I AND READ. AND
YOU REVENUE WE THINK THIS IS A
GREAT STEP FORWARD AND RESPONSE
A PROPOSED AND VERY CRUEL THAT
WERE PROPOSED THEN MAYBE BY I'M-
FOR CLEANING OF COLOR IN
PARTICULAR THE BLACK CAN HELP
PROGRAM HELP NAVIGATORS. AND
THINGS OF THE LIKE SO- JUST
REALLY HOPE TO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL. URGE LEGISLATURE CAN
THINK ABOUT EQUITY AND THE HURT
BOTH NOT VULNERABLE THANK YOU
CAN I. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
LINE THIRTY LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO GOOD MORNING MY NAME
DONALD MILLER AND I WITH
MATERNAL AND CHILD BLOCK WITH A
LOT ANGELES AND I'D LIKE CALL.
WE ARE SUPPORT FOR HEATING
FIVE. AND FOR ALL THE- TO.
INCREASE REVENUE. TO AVOID. THE
CUT TO. NAVIGATOR AND
PARTICULAR TO THE CUT IN THE
MEDIC PROGRAM. THE BILL MANY.
SENIORS AND LOW INCOME PEOPLE
TO. OF THE- SENIOR PENALTY THE
CUT IT. AND I AFFECT THE
REINSTATEMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
MORE ON EARTH THE- RECOVERY
WELL IN THE SHORT TERM IT HERE
THEY MONEY IN THE- TERM. PEOPLE
WILL. LACK OF ACCESS TO HELP
CARE BE AND BE PRESENTING WITH
MARK CONDITIONS WHICH WITHOUT
COST MORE NOT TO MENTION THE
MORAL INEQUITY OF ARE ALWAYS
BALLOT IN THE BACK THE BUDGET
ON THE BACK OF THE POOR THE
MOST VULNERABLE THE FEDERAL WE
APPLAUD YOUR EFFORTS- TO-
PRETTY EIGHTY FIVE AND- A CREW.
YOU TO. LOOK FOR FURTHER TO
INCREASE REVENUE. SO THAT WE DO
NOT AND THE BALLOT IN OUR
BUDGET ON THE BACK OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITY MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS ONE MINUTE. NINE
THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CAMERA DIMITRI WITH TECH NOT
TAKEN AS OPPOSED TO A. B.
EIGHTY FIVE FOR THE INCLUSION
OF THE NET OPERATING LOSS
SUSPENSION AND BUSINESS TAX
CREDIT LIMITATION. WE WOULD
LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COM OPPOSED
COME BUT IN ADDITION IT ISN'T
TO NOTE THAT THE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT TAX CREDIT IS
PRIMARILY BASED ON WAGES PAID
ARE IN THE PROCESSIONAL FOR
ACTIVITY THAT MUST OCCUR IN
CALIFORNIA. TESTIFYING BE
CREDIT COULD BE CONSIDERED AS A
TAX CREDIT TO HIRE AND KEEP
EMPLOYED WELL PAID ARE IN THE
PROFESSIONALS IN A TIME OF
RECORD HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO SENATOR
MITCHELL IT. PEOPLE RECALL
LONGTIME THOSE. THE OF YOU WHO
DON'T KNOW ME. THE WHOLE- AT
THE CALL DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES CLIENT
CLIENT YOUR ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
SERVING COLUSA EL DORADO NEVADA
PLANS SPECTRUM. YEAH SUTTER
YOLO AND YOU COUNTY AND THAT
WHILE I HAVE THE OF THE
LEGISLATURE COMING TO AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE GOVERNOR I
AM VERY SCARED BECAUSE I'M
AFRAID WHAT CUTS TO
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES ABOUT
EACH OF SATISFYING YOU KNOW I
WILL FEEL OSTRACIZED AND- I
NEED AMONG. THE SERVICES FOR
MEDI CAL I- DENTAL CARE AND
ALSO PODIATRY- WELL MEDICARE'S
MY PRIMARY MEDICARE IS MY
PRIMARY INSURANCE BALLOT
BECAUSE LOOK AT THIS HE I DO
NOT SSI RESIDENTS PINI MORE.
BUT BECAUSE THEY DON'T SEE AS
WELL AS I USED TO WHEN I NEED
TO GO TO SPEND WHAT I NEED WHAT
I NEED TO GO TO USE YES OR
STANFORD. NOW BE UP. TO GET THE
TREATMENT FROM RIGHT NOT OF THE-
PROBLEMS. I HAVE TO RELY ON
EMERGE MAY TRANSFER. AND THAT
UNLESS LIKE YOU GET. TREATMENT
UNLESS LIKE. HELLO I CAN GET A
MEDICARE AT THE PLAN THAT. THAT
COVERS ALL MY EXISTING DOCTORS
AND WHERE THEY'RE LOCATED. IT
ALSO COVERS NON EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION IF THAT
GOES AWAY I'M GOING TO HAVE TO
PAY FOR NON EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION OUT OF POCKET IN
MY MOM THAT WHO CONTROLS ALL MY
SSD I MONEY WILL SAY ABSOLUTELY
NOT. AND SO THOSE CUTS WILL
HURT IN THE LONG RUN AND I AM
SCARED TO DEATH. THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE LIKE PASSED. WHERE
CUTS WERE MADE. AND AGAIN I'M
JUST GONNA FEEL OSTRACIZED.
IT'S GOOD TO GOOD ON ME IT'S
GOOD TO HEAR YOUR VOICE CAN YOU
WRAP IT UP FOR ME. I'M A LITTLE
BIT I'M GOING TO MAKE YOUR
SENATOR MITCHELL WITH BETTER
WHICH ALONG WITH THAT IT ELSE
TURNING OUT ON THE COMMITTEE SO.
TAKE CARE BYE BYE NOW THANK YOU
AND I'VE ALWAYS APPRECIATED
YOUR PARTICIPATION THE BUDGET
HEARINGS THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NEXT OPEN LINE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WE- COUNTY HEALTH
DIRECTOR JUST SHARED. LIKE TO
ACT THE COMMON MADE BY CALL ON
BE TURNING BY. PUBLIC EDUCATION
COUNTY ECHO IN OUR- APPRECIATE
FOR THE LEGISLATURE OCT.
REALIGNMENT ABOUT NINE ONE AND
ELEVEN REALIGNED UP ONE DAY
DOLLAR BOND I'M- THE NOT
PARTICULARLY A MENTAL HEALTH
AND YOU CAN ORDER TREATMENT WE
ARE SEEING INCREASED NEED AFTER
BOB HI. MEDIC HOW MOMENT AT THE
SAME TIME THAT WE ARE NOW
REVENUE DECLINE TO YOUR THAT
LEGISLATURE YOU MAY. TO BOTTOM
LINE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND NUMBER THE COLD WAR
LIMóN ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUNBURN AND BEING A COUNTY
BOARD OF. IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE WONDER DOLLAR BACK IT'LL
PROVIDED IN THE LATE BUDGET FOR
RELY THAT IS PROJECTED READ
REALIGNMENT HAD NOW HAVE POWER
DRAFT OVER THE LAST SIX MONTHS.
THE RESULT OF THE IS THAT AND
I'M OF CAL PROGRAM THAT SERVES
THE MONTH FULLER THROUGH REALLY.
INCLUDING HOW HEALTH CARE HOW.
OTHER HELPING HIM SERVICE AND
WELL AS PUBLIC SAFETY OR
JEOPARDY. WE ARE ABOUT NOT
BEING ABLE TO MAKE SERVICE TO
OUR RESIDENTS IN A TIME WHEN
THEY ARE IN NEED. FOR ORANGE
AND SAN BRUNO COUNTY EXTREMELY
APPRECIATE OF THE ONE DOLLAR
THAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
WITNESS. IF THE ARE ANY. LINE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS DOCTOR NO YOU CAN ASK
THE AND THE I WHICH WITH A
DISABILITIES AND I'M IN THE AND
GRAY WE CAN ABOUT THE CUT THAT
I HAD THAT THE- A TERMS OF
REIMBURSED HEARD ABOUT OF
GREENING I. OUR WITH KEEP THE
TROUT. I CANNOT JOIN THE CALL
TO VOICE THEIR CONCERNS OR
THEIR VOICES WELL WE HAVE THAT
AS BILL COME BALLY HERE MAKING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THE AND I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO EVERY
AFFECT OUR PRIORITIES AND OUR
STRATEGY AND THAT. THE YOU.
THANK YOU. THERE IS. WE HAVE
ONE ADELINE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I GOOD MORNING
OFFICIAL GIVEN THAT THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION FOR
THE LEGISLATURE'S PART OF A ONE
BILLION DOLLAR BACK.
REALIGNMENT AFTER THE BACK FILL
OUR IMPACT FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
WOULD HAVE BEEN A LOT OF A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE MILLION
IN THE CURRENT YEAR AND ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO MILLION
IN THE BUDGET YEAR. AND AS YOU
KNOW RIGHT NOW PUBLIC THERE
WITH THE HEALTH SERVICES ARE
VITAL WE PLAY A ROLE IN THE
RESPONSE THAT BIRTH AND WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE THAT.
THANK YOU. AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU. X.
BUT MY- THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
MODERATOR JUST ONE OF MY SURE
THAT THEY IS NO ONE ELSE ADD ON
SINCE YOU ARE NOW. NO NO ONE
OUT OF CUBA THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE NAY
OF THE- WILL NEXT PROCEED TO
VOTING. WILL START WITH THE
FIRST BILL AB SEVENTY FIVE IS
THERE A MOTION FOR AB SEVENTY
FIVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY- CENTER Y. CASKEY.
SENATE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AB SEVENTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS SENATORS
MITCHELL FIVE MITCHELL AYE
NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE WELL.
WELL I HAVE A YELLOW FOR YOU
KNOW AYE DOLLY. THE I DID ALSO.
HI BUT ALSO I OR DOT. LEYVA BY
LABOR I'M NOT. MCGUIRE ONLINE
MELENDEZ. MONEY MONNING AYE
MORLOCK MORE LIKE I MORRELL.
PAN HI AND I ROTH I READ AYE
SKINNER OUR SKINNER AYE STERN
HI STERN AYE WHY BECAUSE HI
ACOSTA HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS HURTADO.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE MORRELL
HI MARA HI. AT SEVENTEEN I IS
NO ZERO THANK YOU OF THE VOTE
OF SEVENTEEN I KNOW ZERO THE
MOTION- THE MOTION CARRIES THIS
PATH OF THE COMMITTEE LET'S
MOVE ON TO. AB SEVENTY SIX
ELEMENT IN A MOTION SO MOVED.
IT'S BEEN MOVED THANK YOU BYE
SENATOR LEYVA SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AB SEVENTY SIX
THE MOTION IS THE PAST CENTERS
MITCHELL MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I TELL THE ICE OF A
YEAR AGO HI. I DOLLY. DALI EYES
THAT ALSO. AWESOME I FOR TITLE
LEYVA. BY LEYVA I LOVE. MCGUIRE
I MELINDA. MELENDEZ I MONEY.
MONEY I'M MORE LAW MORE LIKE
ONLINE OR. I CAN PAN I DRAW.
ROTH AYE SKINNER HI HI STERN
STERN I LIKE CLUNKY BY BECAUSE
HE I. SEVENTEEN I AND THOSE
ZERO SEVENTEEN FIVE ZERO THE
MOTION CARRIES THE TREE WITH
PASSED OUT OF COULD. MOVING ON
A EIGHTY FIVE ALL IN TO THE
MALL SO MOVED INTO LEVEL CALL.
STEVE HAS SENATORS MITCHELL
FIVE MITCHELL NEED. NO NIELSEN
NO BELL. WELL I HAVE A YELLOW
PINE FOR A YOU KNOW I THE ONLY.
DAWALY NO THEY'RE ALSO. ALSO I
TITLE LEYVA BY LABOR I AM A HI
MY BY I MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO
MON. MONEY I MORE LAW MORE LIKE
NO. AROUND MORRELL NO HAN AND
NO I'M SORRY PET ROTH. ROTH AYE
SKINNER. SKINNER STERN BY STERN
I AWAY BECAUSE HI BECAUSE THE I.
THE I TWELVE A NO FIVE PRICED
NO FIVE THE MEASURE PASSES A
KERRY FROM PASSES OUT OF OUR
COMMITTEE LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY AS WELL
AS REPRESENTATIVES FROM FIRE
ANTS IN LA WHO PROVIDED US-
THEIR- ACTIVE IN EXPERT
TESTIMONY THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR YOUR THE CORPORATIONS WITH
INCLUDE THE AGENDA THE SENATE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE STANDS ADJOURNED.